in this course you will learn about
javascript dom manipulation this is
where you use javascript to modify
change or delete elements of a website
in the first part of this course you
will learn the basic features of a
website dom and the javascript commands
you can use to manipulate the dom in the
second part of the course you will use
what you have learned to create
practical examples from beginner to
advanced this course was created by code
lab
so just before we begin we're just going
to take a look at a few prerequisites so
this two-part tutorial is primarily for
beginners so if you've never heard about
the dom or maybe you're a little
familiar with it but don't know how to
utilize and apply it this tutorial is
for you
now in order to effectively understand
the dom and how it relates to working
with the web it's necessary to have an
existing knowledge of html and css and i
have crash courses on both of those if
you want to check those out before you
start this tutorial it's also super
beneficial to have a familiarity with
fundamental javascript so the syntax and
the code structure if you guys want to
learn about fundamentals of javascript
check out my javascript crash course
which covers the fundamentals so there's
a couple things you'll need if you want
to follow along this tutorial you're
going to need a web browser and a code
editor now these are all the options you
can use and you can mix up these options
if you like but this tutorial i'm just
going to be using chrome and visual
studio code again you guys can choose
any combination you like now the
structure of this tutorial we're first
going to take a look at what the dom is
then we're going to take a look at
methods to select elements in the dom
how we can traverse the dom how we can
manipulate the dom and then finally
we're going to take a look at event
handling so we'll start this off by
explaining what the dom is so the dom
stands for document object model now the
document object is a built-in object
that has many properties and methods
that we can use to manipulate the
content the structure and the style of a
project and this ability to manipulate
the dom or the document object model is
one of the most unique and useful
abilities in javascript so almost any
time a website performs an action such
as toggling a navigation menu or
rotating between slideshow images or
even displaying an error when a user
attempts to submit an incomplete form
this is the result of javascript
accessing and manipulating the dom now
another way of thinking about the dom
and understanding how it works is
thinking of it as a tree of nodes like
you can see on the screen now so this is
just a basic diagram of a dom tree and
all of its nodes now everything in this
diagram is a type of node the elements
the attributes the text content and even
line breaks and comments which we'll see
a bit later on are even considered nodes
and all of these make up the dom tree
now the dom object itself is actually a
property of the window object which is
the global top level object representing
a tab in the browser and this window
object has access to such information as
toolbars the height and width of the
window prompts and even alerts but in
this tutorial we're only interested in
the document object which is what is
inside of the inner window and the stuff
we want to manipulate now another
important thing to note here is that
most of these nodes in this diagram have
a parent child sibling relationship the
topmost node are either document node
here is the root node of the dom tree
which we use to access the dom and
manipulate all of the content now this
document node has one child node which
is the html element and the html element
is a parent node to the head and the
body element
now the head and body elements are what
you would call siblings since they're on
the same level in the dom tree
underneath the head element you see it
has one child node which is the title
element and the text this is my website
is a child node of the title element and
these relationships are similar over the
other side but the body element is the
parent of the paragraph and the h1 the
paragraph and the h1 are siblings to
each other and the text content inside
each of these elements are child nodes
to the paragraph and h1 so the my link
and my header our child nodes to the h1
and the paragraph element now we can
also see by the paragraph tag we have a
class attribute now html attributes such
as ids or classes in this case styles
etc also considers nodes in the dom
hierarchy but they don't actually
participate in this parent child sibling
relationship like the other nodes do the
way they are accessed is through
properties of the element node that
they're contained in now often there
will be times you want to move
throughout the dom so understanding this
parent-child sibling relationship is
crucial to understanding how javascript
works with html
all right guys so now we know a little
bit more about what the dom is and learn
about the dom tree the next thing to
cover in the tutorial is how to select
these nodes or elements in the dom tree
for manipulation so before we take a
look at all these methods of selecting
elements let's just quickly go over the
layout you see here in the browser so in
the index.html file
we've got a div of the class of
container
inside of that we've got a heading which
has the id of main heading and then the
text our favorite movie franchise
underneath that we have a ul tag which
has five list items inside of it and
then each of these list items have a
class of list items so super creative
now this is what we're going to be
working on when we're looking at
selecting styling traversing and
manipulating for the rest of this
tutorial and then underneath that we
have a script tag
which has the attribute of source and
this is just linked to the
app.js file
so again guys in order to be able to
manipulate an element in the dom tree we
first have to select that particular
element now luckily for us there's
several ways we can do this and the five
major ways of selecting the elements are
the ones you see on the screen now so
we've got get element by d get element
by class name tag name query selector
and query selector all now some of these
methods are pretty self-explanatory but
we're going to go over each of them one
by one now so the first one we're going
to go over is get element by id and as
you probably guess you can select an
element using this method by its unique
id and this is the easiest way to find
the html element inside the dom tree
because as we know from css the id
attribute is used for something unique
now if we remember back to the html file
you can see that we've got the h1 here
which you see in the browser has the id
of main heading so this is the element
we're going to be selecting so first we
need to select the document object model
which is just simply document then get
the method of get element by id
single quote marks really important that
you include those and then we're just
going to grab
the id which is main heading
close that off now what we can do with
this selection is actually place it
inside of variables so we can manipulate
it so
we're going to go at the front here and
just say const
title and we'll set this to the id of
main heading and if we log this into the
console now
so we'll just look in title you see it
shows up on the console now and if i
hover over this you can see it
highlights in the browser there so you
know now we've selected this element and
then what we can do from here is now
select that variable we just created for
the element and we can add styles to the
element manipulate its attributes
traverse the element so all of that good
stuff which we'll be looking at in just
a moment
now next we have the element by class
name again quite self-explanatory this
method returns a collection of all the
elements in the document with that
specified class name so for example in
our html file here you can see all of
our list items have that really creative
class name of list items so we can
select all of these using the get
element by class name method
so we'll do the same thing we'll put
inside a variable we'll just say list
item
and we'll set it to the document
we'll say get element by class name
put single quote marks in there and then
we'll just say
list
items i think it's items yes items and
then we'll just log this in the console
so we know we've selected that element
or these elements
and as you can see using the method of
get elements by class name we've now
selected all of those elements now this
method actually returns an array like
object of all the child elements which
have all the given class names so if we
open this up you can see it's indexed
and they're in the order that they are
in the html file
now the next method here which is get
element by tag name is pretty similar to
the get element by class name and that
accepts a tag name and returns all of
the elements of that specified tag name
in the order in which they appear in a
document so again return an array like
object for all the child elements with
the given tag name so for this example
i'm going to do is just copy and paste
the class name
example comment this out
and then we'll just say
tag name
and because the list items are list
items we just type in li and if we take
a look at the console now you can see
it's got that html collection of all the
five list items and they're all indexed
in the order that they appear in the
html file so you can see this method is
pretty similar to the
getelementbyclassname method
now the query selected method that you
see here is used to select one item or
the first item that matches the selector
is given so if you have multiple items
with the same class name or the same id
or even the same tag it will select the
first one it comes across so the beauty
of this method as you probably just
guessed is that it can accept all css
style selectors again allowing it to
select it by its tag or its class or
even its id so we can actually use this
method to actually grab
any element in our html file here so
what i'm going to do is use it to grab
the div of the class of container which
is acting as a container for the rest of
the content
so
we'll just go underneath here
and we'll create a variable and we'll
keep it super creative and call it
container and we'll grab the document
and then grab the query selector method
and again with this method we can grab
the div tag or we can grab the class
name or if i had an id attribute we can
grab that instead what i'm going to do
is grab the div tag
and then just log this into the console
so we know it's working
and as you can see in the console now
using the query selector method we've
selected that uh div with a class of
container
now as i just mentioned when we're using
the query selector it selects the first
item that matches the selector it's
given which in this case is the div now
if we go into the index.html file and we
use several more divs
again it's only going to select this
first div here
if we had more divs in this example and
we wanted to select them all we then use
the query selector all instead
so uh what i'm going to do actually is
just duplicate this
uh one more time
uh just zoom out a little bit and then
uh just going to change a bit of the
word in here so favorite
sports
and i'm not gonna bother changing the
names here but just to show you guys
that it selects all of them i'm just
gonna copy
and paste this but instead of query
selector we're gonna say query selector
all and then
comment this out
and quickly just comment all these out
so we can only see
that variable there
and if you take a look at the console
now you can see that this method returns
a node list of collections of all the
matching elements that matches that
specific css selector which in this case
is a div so similar to the get by tag
name and get by class name where we get
html collection
in this method we get a node list and as
you can see it selected both of the
containers
because unlike the query selector with
query selector all it's selecting all of
the divs in the index.html file so
that's how we can select elements with
the query selector and the
queryselectoral method so to quickly
summarize this section when you need to
select a dom element you have five
different options to choose from five
different ways of essentially doing the
same thing which is selecting an element
or elements
personally i primarily use query
selector and query select all because
these methods select elements through
css selection and i primarily use this
to select ids and classes mainly because
these css selectors provide a really
powerful and efficient way of selecting
html documents especially ids because
you likely understand that elements
shouldn't have the same id that the id
is a unique identifier of that element
within the document so with that in mind
selecting an element with its id is a
safe bet because you wouldn't go and
apply manipulation to different elements
unless perhaps that's what you want to
achieve in that case the query select
all method and the class selector is
what i typically use so now we know all
the different methods that we can use to
select an element in the dom tree we
could finally start doing some
manipulating now so firstly what we'll
do is just get rid of all of this
content here
and then head in the index.html file and
just get rid of the second container so
we don't really need it
so let's start things off by taking a
look at how we can change the styling of
an element so if you are familiar with
css and css properties we have a way we
can access these properties in
javascript so the first thing we'll do
is just select this main heading which
we have in our index.html file here
which is just the title of the container
and so we're going to put that in a
variable
and we'll call this variable title
and then document.queryselector
method and we'll grab the id of this
element which is main
heading
oh i need to put these in a
single quote marks
and then let's just log this in the
console so we know
this variable is working and as you can
see now we've selected this element and
stored inside the
variable of title so what we can do now
is actually manipulate the starting of
this element and change it around using
css properties so to access css
properties in javascript we'll just
first grab the variable we want to apply
the styling to which in this case
is the title or the main heading and
then we simply type in the style
property and then after this style
property you just use any css property
you want to apply to this element so
what we'll do is just change the color
of the text
and we'll set this to
let's say red
and as you can see in the browser now
we've changed the color of the main
heading from white to red using the
style property and then the css property
of color now this type of styling is
what you'd call inline styling and there
are other methods to style elements with
javascript but this is probably the most
direct method now again if you take a
look at the console you can see it's
actually included the style attribute
again because this is actually done
through inline styling now it's
important to know this because with
inline styling this actually only works
on a single element if i tried let's say
applying it to all of the list items
here this wouldn't actually work so just
going to demonstrate that to you guys
so let's uh create another variable
and we'll call it list
items
and we'll grab all of those list items
with query selector all
uh they will have
they all have um
a class of list items
and then let's just log in here
list items
uh
so you see now in the console we've
selected all of those list items now
let's try and use the style property
again on these list items and see if it
works so we'll say style
let's say let's try and change the color
again or let's actually do the font size
and just quickly guys i wanted to
mention that it's important to remember
while using the style property css
properties are written in camel case and
not with a more standard snake case
which has the dash so the camel case is
essentially just a capital letter to
begin the second word and any subsequent
word in the name or method or even a
property
font size in css would be written like
this but in javascript we'll use camel
case so just so you guys are aware of
that now again back to what we were
talking about if i tried changing all of
the
font size of these list items here so
let's say to about two rem you can see
this isn't actually working because it's
trying to apply
an inline style to uh five different
list items which wouldn't work if we
actually wanted to apply this styling to
all of the list items we need to loop
through the list items first
so just to show you guys how that would
work
uh we'll say i equals
zero
and then uh we'll say i
is less than the list
dot length which just gives us the
amount of list items
inside of our um ul here which is five
and then we want to say we want this to
increment
by one
each time and then what we do now is
just apply this
and put it inside of our for loop and
then
we just need to index the eye and as you
can see now it's quite subtle so let's
just make it a bit bigger
you can see all of the list items now
have that styling because it's been
looped through using the for loop so
that's how we can apply inline style
into elements um using the style
property or multiple elements if we loop
through them the next thing i want to
take a look at is creating elements so
what i'm going to do is just comment all
of this out first
get rid of
the list items there i'm just going to
put a comment here for
styling
elements
and then now we'll do one for
creating
elements
so again another really cool thing about
dom manipulation is that we can create
elements from our javascript file here
and we do that with a simple method
really of the create element
so let's say we want to add another list
item here in our favorite movie
franchise uh container what we need to
do first is
just create a variable for the unordered
list
um because we need to enter this on
order list
uh so we'll say document dot
query select that
grab the ul
and then what we'll do now is use the
career elements method to create another
list item
so we'll just use another variable here
so document
dot
create
element
and we'll create a list item
now this isn't actually going to do
anything at the moment this element
we've just created in this variable here
needs to be inserted into our document
and the way we can add elements inside
of the document is using the append
method
so what we'll do is first grab the ul
because we want to append this list item
inside this ul
and then we grab the pen method
and the element we want to append which
is the variable of li which again is
just this list item now you won't be
able to see it currently at the moment
but if we take a look at um the document
here and if we open this up
and then open up the div the classic
container open up the ul you can see
there's an extra list item inside of
this ul now because we've inserted this
element now using the append method now
what we can do from here is add some
content inside of our list item
so i'm just going to
bring this back down
go back in the console
and i'm just gonna put a comment here
for
adding
elements
and then off this we're just gonna say
um
modifying the text
now we don't really need this console
log anymore so there are several ways we
can include text or modify text in our
html and those ways are inner text text
content and in html now there is a
difference between three so to
demonstrate those differences i'm just
going to put another html tag inside of
the first list item here
so i'm just going to put a span
i'm going to put neo
because that's relevant to the matrix
and then i'm just going to create
another variable
to grab that element there so we're
going to say first
list
item
set that to the document
and say query selector and then we'll
grab that list item
and then i'm just going to grab the
console log again actually and put in
here first
list item
oh forgotten s
so there's our first list item now what
i'm going to do here is include in our
text first
so it just displays the text duplicate
this a couple more times and i'm going
to grab text content
and then also grab
in
html so if i just pull this up a bit
more now if you take a look at the
console you can clearly see the
differences uh between the three now and
that is essentially just the way they're
displayed so within a text here you can
see we're simply getting the visible
text contained inside that node with
text content you see it's actually being
displayed the same way it is in the html
file so it's got all those indents and
it's jumping onto a new line
and within html a similar sort of thing
with the indents and jumping on new
lines but it's also showing the tags so
showing us the span tags inside of our
html here so again that's pretty much
the differences between the three now
another thing here is that within a html
there is a bit of a danger using inner
html and that's mainly at security
issues you don't really want user input
to be displayed in the inner html
because this actually allows the user to
control the javascript and the html on
your web page which obviously has its
problems there so in most cases you're
just going to use inner text so let's go
ahead and use that and implement that in
our list item that we created
so we're just going to grab the li grab
in a text
and
we're going to set this
to equal
let's say x-men which is another
franchise if you take a look at the
browser now you can see that text has
been included inside of our list item
now all right guys so we've created our
list item here we've added it into the
ul using the append method and we've
also given it some text the next thing i
want to do now is make our list item
look like the rest of the list items so
to do that we're going to need to learn
how to modify and manipulate an
element's attributes or classes luckily
for us javascript provides several
methods and properties for add-in
removing or changing the html elements
attributes or classes
so we're going to go underneath here and
just put a comment of
modifying
attributes
and classes
and the first method we're going to take
a look at is the set attribute method
so we'll grab our list item and we'll
say set attribute and as you probably
guessed because it's pretty
self-explanatory what it does is set an
attribute to our specified element which
in this case is our list item so for
this attribute we need to include two
values the first is the attribute you
want to set which will just put an id
and then the second is the name you want
to give that attribute so we'll just
give this attribute let's say
let's give it the id of main heading
and as you can see in the browser now
because we've given this list item the
same id as our main heading here which
is main heading
you can see it's got the exact same
styling so as you can see the set
attribute method is quite powerful now
the next method i want to take a look at
is how we can actually remove this
attribute so we'll go underneath here
and we'll say li dot
remove
attribute
again pretty self-explanatory so let's
say we want to remove the id from our
list item there all we put in here is
just id
close that off and you can see now it's
reverted back to its default styling and
doesn't have that styling that the main
heading does now there's also a way we
can access attributes in javascript so
which follows a similar sort of method
so we'll say let's say we want to get
the attribute of our
main heading here what we need to do is
first let's just create a variable for
it so const
and we'll say title
equals document
dot query selector
and then grab the
main heading
and then let's just log this in the
console so we'll say um title dot get
attribute
that we want is the id
and as you can see in the console now
it's giving us main heading which is the
id associated with our main heading here
so that's how we can deal with
attributes here let's take a look at how
we can deal with classes
so i'll just get rid of all of this and
we'll grab our list item again and then
we'll use the property of class list now
this classlist property has quite a few
methods we can utilize and the first one
we'll take a look at is how we can use
the add method which of course will just
add a class to our list item so we'll
say dot add
so let's say list
items
and as you can see when we add that
class now our last list item here is the
exact same styling as the other list
items because again we've added the same
class as the rest of the list items now
what we can also do here is remove this
so we'll say
remove
and again it will just revert back to
its default styling because of course
we've removed that class now
now another thing we can find out is
whether an element has that specific
class
so um i'm just going to log this item
into the console here class list and
we'll use the method of contains
and we're going to find out if it
contains
list items
and as you can see it's returning us
false because of course we remove that
class now
up here so it's giving us false if we
change this method to add instead you
see now it's returning us true because
of course a list item here now does
contain uh this class here
so that's how we can modify attributes
and classes in the dom of course the dom
has many more methods than this but
these are just some of the core methods
you'll likely need to use now there is
still one method left to use and that's
how we can remove an element and the
method to remove an element or our list
item in this case is a pretty simple
method to remember i'm just putting here
first remove
elements
so all we need is the remove method so
we'll say li dot
remove and if you take a look at the
console now you can see that the list
item has been removed and if we just
open up
all of the elements and we'll open up
the div here
and open up our url you can see that
list item is no longer there so we've
learned quite a bit about the dom now
we've learned how to access elements and
dom we've also learned how to create add
modify style and remove elements in the
dom too the next thing i want to take a
look at is how we can navigate the dom
so i'm just going to bring you guys back
to the slide which we looked at at the
beginning of this video where we have a
really basic diagram of a dom tree and
all of its nodes now everything in this
diagram that you see here is a type of
node so that includes the elements the
attributes the text content and even
line breaks and comments inside the html
document are considered nodes and all
these together make up the dom tree now
the dom object itself is actually a
property of the window object which is
the global top level object representing
the tab in the browser the window object
has access to so much information such
as the toolbar the height the width of
the window
even things like prompts and alerts but
in this tutorial we're only interested
in the document object which is what is
inside of the inner window and the stuff
that we want to manipulate now if you
also remember back to the beginning of
this tutorial
most of these nodes in this diagram have
a parent child sibling relationship the
top most note i.e the document node is
the root node of the dom tree which we
use to access the dom and manipulate all
the content now this document node here
has one child node the html element the
html element is a parent node to the
head and the body elements now the head
and body elements are what you would
call siblings since they're at the same
level in the dom tree underneath the
head element you see it has a child node
which is the title element and the text
this is my website is a child node of
the title
element these relationships similar over
on the other side here where the body
element is parent to the paragraph and
the h1 the paragraph and h1 are siblings
and the text content inside of each of
these elements are child nodes so the my
link and then my header are child nodes
the h1 and the paragraph element as you
can see here we also have a class
attribute and html attributes such as
ids styles classes etc also considered
as nodes in the dom hierarchy but they
don't actually participate in the parent
child relationship like other nodes do
they're accessed as properties of the
element node that contains them so they
would be a property of the paragraph tag
for example in this diagram now often
there will be times where you want to
move through the dom without specifying
each and every element or node
beforehand so learning how to traverse
the dom tree is essential to
understanding how to work with
javascript and html so let's head back
into vs go now and look at the different
ways we can traverse the dom
alright guys so it's pretty drilled in
now that we're aware that the dom is
full of different types of nodes which
have parent child sibling relationships
and if we just head into the html file
here just to see this in action you can
see that the html element is the parent
of the head and body element and the
body element is the parent to the div
but not the h1 here or the ul since
these are two levels down from the body
now the h1 and the ul are what you would
call siblings because they're on the
same level
so what we're going to do here is use
this ul and traverse upwards in the dom
and find out what the parent of the ul
is and also the grandparent so we'll
head back into the app.js file and go
underneath parent no traversal and let's
just first create a variable to grab
that ul so we'll say let
ul
equals document
dot query selector
and then grab the ul
and then just log this in the console
so we've got a ul then you can see it
hovers over it and as you know nodes in
the dom are referred to as parents
children or siblings depend on the
relationship to other nodes now the
parent of any node is a node that is one
level above it or closer to the document
in the dom hierarchy so to find out the
parent node here we have two options so
the first option
is parent node
duplicate this
and we also have parent element and as
you can see in the console now we're
getting the div with the class of
container because this is the parent of
the ul here
now say we wanted to actually traverse
upwards again and find out the
grandparent of the ul all we need to do
is double down by chaining the property
together so after parrot node we just
write paranoid again
and we'll do the same thing with parent
element
and as you can see now in the console
we're getting the output of body because
two levels up from the ul here first is
a container and then the body so as you
can see what we've done here is managed
to traverse up the dom tree from the ul
to figure out what the grandparent is so
it's really useful to know these kind of
properties now you may be wondering what
the difference is between these two and
it will make more sense when we take a
look at how we can traverse child nodes
in just a moment but basically the clue
is in the name so you can see here we
have parent element and parent node and
we know that elements are a type of node
and this is where it can confuse people
because as we know notes can be text it
can be a document
comments or even line breaks so this
distinction can help grasp the
difference between the two now that
might still confuse you guys a little
bit so i'm just going to show you
this in action so i'm going to comment
all these out and i'm just going to
create a variable for our html element
so we're going to set this to document
dot
document element
and then i'll just log this in the
console again
so we'll log in here html
and you can see we've selected our html
there now i'm going to do the same thing
and apply the parent node and the parent
element property to this html
variable say parent
node duplicate this and we'll say parent
element
and as you can see when we take a look
at the console now the parent element is
returning us null that's because the job
of the parent element property here is
to try and retrieve the parent element
of the html element ie the document node
however the document node and an element
node aren't the same type of node hence
why we're getting this null here so the
parent node property will try to
retrieve any node regardless that type
of node so generally parrot node is more
commonly used when we're traversing the
dom again even if you use parent element
you likely won't run into this problem
so that's how we can navigate upwards of
the dom let's now take a look at how we
can traverse downwards in the dom by
taking a look at the child node
traversals in the dom tree so for this
example we're still going to stick with
the ul and we're going to traverse
downwards into the list items so i'm
just going to comment this out
and then go underneath the comment and
because we're sticking with the ul here
i'm just going to
put this
here so we can see it and i'm just going
to console log in ul now just like the
property of paranormal and parent
element we also have child node
properties and child element properties
which pretty much work in the exact same
way so let's first take a look at the
child nodes property and see what it
gives us so after the ul i'm just going
to type in here
child nodes you can see in the console
now it's giving us a node list and if i
open this up we get a list of every
child node inside of the ul now again
this is where the distinction between
nodes and elements becomes more evident
because you might have expected this
property here to give us the five list
items but in addition to the five list
items six text nodes this is because we
actually wrote out our own html this
wasn't generated by javascript and
inside of the html here the indentation
between element nodes is counted in the
dom tree as text nodes that so just to
show you guys what happens if i remove
one of those indentations so i'm just
going to put this list item
in the same line as the fourth one you
can see now in the node list it's saying
10 instead of 11 again because
indentations are counting as text nodes
so again that distinction between nodes
and element nodes becomes even more
evident
so what we'll do is actually just put
that in another line again so we get a
node list of 11. now as well as this
child noise property here we also have
first and last child and as you probably
guessed this just selects the first and
last child node of our list here
so
i'm just going to duplicate this a few
more times
and for this example we need to write as
just
first child
and
last child
and again this is just returning us text
nodes because if we take a look at the
um node list here you can see that the
first index is a text node and then the
last index is also a text node now when
we're using first chart and last child
here which is selecting the first and
last node we need to be very mindful if
we try styling element using this
property so just to show you guys what i
mean uh if i
grab the ul here
and i say first
child
and we're gonna style
first child
we'll say background
color and we'll set it to
let's say
blue
you can see we're getting an error now
because the first
child here is actually a text node it's
not an element now to select the node we
want to apply this styling to what we
can do instead of using first child here
is grab the
child
nodes
property
and then take a look at the node list
and i think we wanted to apply the style
into this item which is indexed.1
so we grab our square brackets
grab the first index number and if you
take a look at the browser now you can
see that our first list item here has
the background color of blue which we
applied here in this styling now again
like the parent element here we also
have the same thing for the children
elements which is only going to select
the element nodes
so what we'll do is just
comment all these out
and we'll use that ul again
and we'll log in uh let's log in ul and
then grab
children
now instead of a node list you can see
it's returning also html collection and
it says it's five which is these five
list items inside of our ul now again
like first try on our last child we can
do the exact same thing
for the first child elements so we'll
say first
child
element
so that's how we convert downwards into
the dom using child node properties so
lastly now we're just going to take our
sibling no traversal so again knows that
our siblings are nodes that are on the
same tree level in the dom so if we take
a look at our html again we know that
the h1 and the ul are siblings to each
other because they're all on the same
level now it's also important to note
here that siblings don't have to be the
same type of node like they are here as
element nodes if i put a text comment
between the two of these so i'm just
going to put in here
uh
space
between
this too would classify as a sibling to
the h1 and the ul because they're all on
the same level so let's put that in a
visual perspective for you guys so i'll
go back into the app.js file and i'll
underneath this comment here
and i'm just going to grab our uo
again and comment these out
and just log this into the console here
so we get our ul again
now just like the two previous traversal
properties we have properties for node
which covers all the nodes and we also
have properties which just cover element
nodes so let's first take a look at
select all types of nodes so after the
ul here we've got the previous sibling
and if i duplicate this we've also got
the next sibling
and you can see in the console now we're
getting two text nodes and just to show
you why we're getting two text nodes i'm
just gonna create another variable for
our div just call this div
we'll grab the div
and we want to find out
all of the child nodes inside of that
div
oh it's about div wrong
you can see we'll open this up now and
as you can see when we've used these two
properties here we've got the ul before
the ul is a text node and after the ul
is also a text node so that's how these
two properties here are working now
again like the other properties we used
beforehand with parent element and all
of these child element notes we have the
exact same thing for sibling no
traversal so again if you just wanted to
find out the sibling element nodes
instead of using previous sibling and
next sibling we can use
the
previous element sibling
and
we can also use next
element sibling
and i'm just going to comment out this
if you take a look at the console now
you see we're getting the h1 because
this is the previous element sibling
node
um beforehand in the html as you can see
here and then for the next element
sibling we're getting a null because
there's no element nodes after the
ul all right guys so we've gone through
quite a bit of information now regarding
the dom we've looked at what that dom is
we've looked at how we can add elements
to the dom style elements in the dom
remove and modify elements in the dom
and we've just learned how we can
traverse the dom the last topic i want
to cover in this tutorial is taking a
look at event listeners now event
listeners are among the most frequently
used javascript structures in web design
and what they do is basically just allow
us to add interactive functionality to
html elements by listening to different
events that take place on the page such
as when a user presses a key or when
elements load or when a user clicks a
button now the most common events you
might listen out for are load events
touch start events key down events mouse
over events and of course click events
now we'll take a look at some of these
in just a moment and i will leave a link
in the description if you guys want to
check out all the other dumb events but
let's learn about the two most common
ways we can add event listeners in our
projects now the first way we can
include an event is actually inside of
our index.html and directly inside one
of these elements so what this event is
is the global on event attribute and
this way of creating an event to an
element works pretty much like any
attribute we inserted directly into the
html element that's present on the page
or the element we want to apply the
event to and then apply a one line of
script to that particular element which
in this case is going to be this button
here for our first example so we'll go
inside the opening tag here like we did
with any other sort of attribute and
then we include whichever event we'd
like to happen for this example we're
going to use an on click event so we'll
say on click and what i want to fire off
when we click on this button is just to
show us an alert box that has the
content of i love javascript so we'll
put in here
alert and then we'll put the content of
i
love
java
script and that's all we need to write
for this attribute so the syntax for
this as you can see is pretty simple
we've included the on click event
attribute so when we click on the
specific button in the browser now the
event will fire off and the alert
function will be executed which will
have the text i love javascript inside
of it so we'll head into the browser now
and i'm going to click on this button
here
and as you can see when i click on the
button the alert box pops up and it's
got the content of our love javascript
which we wrote inside of this attribute
here so that's the first way we could
include an event in our projects which
is just direct into the html on that
element we will apply the event to so
pretty simple and probably the most
direct method of including an event
listener inside of our project now the
next method to create an event listener
is the javascript ad event listener
method so to create that we'll head back
inside our app.js file and the way this
method works is first include a element
that we want to apply the event listener
to so we'll just put in here element
and then we use the add
event
listener
method and then inside of here we
include the type of event in this
example we'll use another click event
and then after this the second parameter
is the function we want to fire off
and then we also have an option here for
a third parameter which will take in a
boolean data type so true or false and
this is in relation to bubbling and
capturing which we will speak about in a
moment but we're not going to include
that at the moment because by default
it's already false so it's not too
important yet so we'll just close that
off so that's essentially the syntax
i've had an event list now using the ad
event listener method so for this
example we're going to use the example 2
button here and again we're going to
create another alert box
so the first thing we want to do is
create a variable
for us to
reference from so we'll call it button
2.
and
the button
two in the html here you can see has a
class of btn so we're gonna retrieve
that so document.queryselector
and then
grab the btn
2
and then first we want to create a
callback function
so the function we'll call this
alert
btn
and inside of here we'll just put
another alert box
and then type in here i
also love
java
script and then what we need to do now
is include our event listener so i'm
just gonna copy the syntax
paste in here the element
is that button two so we've got our
advent listener method there
and then the function is gonna be that
alert
btn and we've got a little i'm saying oh
we've got the e in listener
so what we've done now is included a
click event on the uh button two which
is this button here so when we click on
this this alert box should fire off and
should appear at the top of the screen
with the content again of i also love
javascript so let's test this out
and as you can see now this event is
working and we're getting our alert box
which has the content of i also love
javascript so that's how we can use the
advantage listener method here
so let's take a look at a another
example for example three so instead of
a click event we'll look at a mouse over
event
so uh
say mouse over here so for this example
instead of clicking on a button here
when i move the mouse over i want the
background of this whole box to change
so to do that let's first grab i think
it's
box three so we'll create a variable for
it
and we'll call this variable new
background color
grab the box so document.query selector
and it's
box
three then we'll first create the
function so we'll say function
change
vg
color
so we'll grab that variable now new
background color
style
dot
background
color
and let's set it to the color of blue
and then uh
we'll now include that mouse over event
so we'll grab the variable add event
listener method
uh and we'll say
mouse over
and then the function which is change
vg color
so if i head over to example three if i
now move the mouse over the box here it
should change its background color to
blue
and as you can see that's working as it
should manage to change the style of our
third box using the mouse over event and
the event listener method now generally
people do tend to use the ad event
listener method more than the html on
event method typically because you can
apply as many event listeners to an
element through the ad event listener
method whereas with the html on event
method you can only apply it once so if
you had one event already on a html
element and then you try to plan another
one that new one would override the old
one but again if you only want to apply
one event the on event method works
perfectly fine so these were some really
basic example guys of how we can
implement event listeners we'll now take
things a little step further by creating
a reveal hide event where we click a
button to display some text which is
originally hidden
all right guys so the really cool thing
about event listeners is that we can
combine them with css and other
javascript tools to create interactive
and fun constructs which for this part
of the tutorial is our simple example
here where we have a button and then
when i click on this button you can see
it reveals more text if i click on the
button again it hides the text now the
html for this example is really simple
so we've got a div here with a colossal
container inside of that div we've got a
button element which has the class of
reveal btn and the class of boxes which
is just a general class underneath that
we have it with a class of hidden
content which has all of our dummy text
inside of it this also has a class of
boxes
and this is what it currently looks like
right now in our live server now the
first thing i want to do here is go into
app.js file and create two constants so
we grab those two elements so the first
one is going to be for our button we'll
just call this
reveal
btn
and then we'll say document
dot query selector
and we'll grab that element which has a
class of reveal btn and then we want to
create another constant for our hidden
section so we'll call this uh
let's call this hidden content
and then document.queryselector
and then grab a class of
hidden
content which i think
yeah
so we've got our two constants there the
next thing i want to do now is create a
callback function which will check if
our hidden content here has the class of
reveal btn now i will explain this in
more depth but for now let's just create
that function so we're going to create
that function we'll call this function
reveal content
and then inside the curly braces here we
want to use an if else statement so
we'll use the if statement first
inside the brackets is our condition so
we'll say
if our hidden content grab the class
list property
contains class of reveal btn
so there's our condition the code that
we want to execute if this condition is
true grab the hidden content grab the
classlist property and we want to
actually remove
this class if it does contain the class
so
we want to remove the class of reveal
btn again this will make more sense in
just a moment but we're just going to
write this out for now
else
if it doesn't contain that class of
reveal btn and we want to grab the
hidden content classes property then we
want to add that class
of reveal
btn
now the next thing we want to do now
is
include our event listener so we want to
apply the event list now on our uh
button here
so say reveal btn
add event listener and we want to look
out for a click event
and then the function we want to run off
is the reveal content function we just
created and the last thing we'll do now
is visually hide our div here which has
the dummy text so we do that inside our
style sheet so we'll go inside the
internal style sheet here
grab the class of hidden
content
and we'll say display none
and then when the function runs off and
it does include our class of reveal btn
we want to grab the hidden content grab
the reveal
btn
class and then we want to display as
block
so this now should be working so if i
click on our button you can see it
reveals our paragraph i click on the
button again it hides the content so
what we're essentially saying here is
that depending on the current state of
our hidden content here javascript will
either add or remove the reveal btn
class so in its current state right now
this button here does not have the class
of reveal btn and hence why it's not
displaying because we've set this here
to none when we do click on this button
it will display as block because we've
added our event listener here which
looks out for a click it will run
through this function it will check here
if it does contain the reveal btn which
it doesn't so if it doesn't we've got
our else statement here which will add
that class will reveal btn and because
we've set it as block here it will now
display it if we click on the button and
as you can see it's displaying it now
and if we click on this button again it
will run through our function here and
it will first check if it contains the
class of reveal btn which it does
currently in this state so it will
remove that class of btn and because in
our internal style sheet here we've set
the display to none it will effectively
hide our content and just show us the
button here so if i just show you guys
what that looks like if i just comment
out the remove section if i click on the
button it will display it because
currently right now it's added the class
of reveal btn if i click on this now you
can see now it's still displaying the
text because in our if statement here we
no longer have the ability to remove
that class so that's how we can create
really basic reveal hard functionality
using event listeners which looks pretty
simple but this technique actually can
be used for many different things so for
instance you can use it for things like
toggling a menu on small screens so when
you see that hamburger menu or you can
display error messages with this and
many more things you can do so guys
that's how we can create events in
javascript how we can fire off different
types of events and again there are
loads of different types of events we
can create and i'll leave a link in the
description for you guys if you guys
want to check those out now this is
actually just scratching at the surface
of event listeners there are some things
lurking underneath or more appropriately
put lurking behind the scenes of event
listeners and that is event propagation
and event delegation let's first take a
look at what event propagation is and
what it means now event propagation
refers to how an event travels through
the document object model or the dom
tree and you can think of event
propagation as electricity running
through a wire until it reaches its
destination now as we're fully aware the
dom is full of nodes and when referring
to event propagation and events the
event needs to pass through every node
on the dom until it reaches the end or
is forcibly stopped
now event propagation is also the
umbrella term which is used to cover
three phases when dealing with event
listeners you first got the event
capturing then you've got the target and
then you've got the event bubbling now
in the simplest definition the capturing
phase starts from the root and travels
all the way to the target after it's
reached the target it goes into the
bubbling phase which travels back up
from the target to the root so to better
understand this let's take a look at a
visual representation of the event
propagation so in this slide you can see
we have a basic diagram of our three
phases now imagine that our button at
the bottom here has a click event
attached to it and is being clicked now
when this happens javascript behind the
scenes starts three phases first it
begins with the capture phase where it
starts at the highest level of the dom
and it'll trickle all the way down i
will notify each element so it will
notify the html element the body and the
div and tell it that something
underneath it is being clicked so again
going back to that analogy of
electricity running through a wire so
this will trickle until it reaches the
target phase this phase is a dom node in
which we click so in our example the
button here at the bottom has a click
event attached to it so this would be
the target and essentially our target
phase so once this target phase is
triggered the next phase is what we'd
call the bubbling phase which is
essentially just the opposite of the
capture phase this travels back up the
dom and notifies every element so the
div the body the html the document all
the way up to the highest level period
of the target again this is all
happening behind the scenes and it's
almost instantaneous so let's go ahead
into vs code now and take a look at what
this looks like in the browser and the
console all right guys so we're inside
this code here and you can see in our
example here we have several elements
nesting inside of each other if you take
a look at the html the markup is pretty
simple for this so we've got our div
which has a class of div two inside of
that we've got another div with the
class of div one and then inside of that
div we have a button element so this is
what it looks like in the browser and as
you can see it just has some basic
styling now if we head into the
javascript here you can see we have
event listings on pretty much everything
in the dom tree so we've got one for the
window we've got one for the document
we've got one for the div two div one
and then the button here now as you can
see i've set this up a little bit
differently in regards to the event
listeners instead of creating a variable
for the window the document as well as
the elements here i've just added the
event listeners directly after now
creating a variable and doing it this
way both work perfectly fine but for
this example there's less code here and
it just saves me scrolling up and down a
bunch of times which can be a pain for
people now in regards to the events
themselves you can see their click
events and as for the functions they
just simply log in their respective name
in the dom tree except for the button
here now instead of the text you can see
we've included an e inside of the
functions parameters as well as the
inside the function we're logging in
that e now i will explain what this is
in just a moment but first i just want
to draw your attention to the third
parameter inside of all these event
listeners so if i highlight them all for
you now
you can see they all have a boolean
value of true now if you guys remember
back to a bit earlier in the video when
we were learning about the ad event
listener method there was a third
optional parameter we could include well
this the parameter dictates whether we
want to use event capture or event
bubbling so let's go ahead and click on
the button here in the browser and see
what this gives us in the console so as
you can see now in the console it's
giving us the first phase which is the
capture phase so it's starting from the
window and then it's going down and
notifying all the other elements it
comes across all the way down to the
target which is saying is this pointer
event
now the stuff that you see here
represents all of the information about
that event so this is exactly what that
e means inside of our function here
which is inside of our button so this e
represents the event object and again
this is exactly what you see here in the
console all this information is about
that event that has occurred on this
button so if i open this up you can see
all the different properties and
information about our event here so
we've got all sorts of things we can
take a look at and utilize so we can
find out what type it is we know it's a
click event we can check out where
exactly that button is exactly on the
screen in a browser on the x and y axis
we can also check things like whether
the shift key here has been pushed down
same false because we didn't use the
shift key
so all sorts of things that we can use
here and utilize now the main property i
want to bring your attention to and the
relevant one to the three phases is the
target property here so this here you
can see it's saying the button so this
property represents the element that the
event is actually on so again it relates
to our target phase so if i actually go
into our console here and i type in here
dot target
and i'll just refresh this and i click
on the button again you can see now it's
starting from the window going to the
document div two div one because we're
using the target property to show us
what element the event is on which again
is our button now again we can do some
other cool things here so let's just say
for example when we click on this button
um we'll just change the text to say
clicked so after the target
we say dot in our text and set this to
equal it to
say clicked
so what should happen if i click on the
button it should change the text to
click so as you can see now in the
console when we've clicked the button
it's changing the text to click because
what we've done is use the event object
to grab the target which is the button
and then from there we use the inner
text property and then change it to
click so when this function files off
the buttons text change to click so as
you can see here in the browser and if
you also take a look at the console you
can see we also see phase one so the
capturing phase so we start the window
document div two div one and then click
which is the button so that's the first
and second phase how do we now initiate
the third phase which is the bubbling
phase well to do that all we need to do
is just grab all of the true values here
for our third parameter
and just change them to false now these
are actually false by default and if i
click on the button now
you can see it started from the button
and then it's going to div 1 div 2
document and then the window so it's
bubbling upwards hence the term event
bubbling so from the target it's
bubbling up to the highest position in
the dom tree now there are ways we can
actually stop event propagation so let's
just say we wanted to stop the bubbling
um to happen at the second div we can do
that with the stop propagation method
so let's go to the second div here
include our event object
then inside of here we'll just say
e dot stop
propagation so what should happen now is
when i click on this button once it
reaches the second div we want the
propagation to stop so we'll no longer
be able to see the events on the
document and the window so if i click on
this you can see it's going from click
to div one div two because we've stopped
the propagation in our function here now
this also applies to event capturing so
if i grab all of the third parameters
here and change them to true so we're in
the capture phase
and then i click on this button you can
see the opposite is happening because
we're starting from the window where the
cap where the capture phase begins then
goes to the document and then goes to
div two and then stops at div two
because we've stopped the propagation so
that's how we can stop event propagation
happening forward capturing and bubbling
another useful ability we can utilize an
event bubbling is to have events far off
only once
so for this example again we'll use div
two and i'm just going to comment out
the stop propagation method there
take out the e and then
change with these two false even though
they're false by default um we'll just
keep it like this for consistency so
again if we only want div two to fire
off once for our third parameter here
what we can do is grab the once property
and set this to true now if i click on
this button you can see it fires it all
off as normal so it starts from the
click and bubbles up all the way to the
window if i now click this button again
you can see it's starting from the
button or the target going to div one
but now dev2 is no longer firing
and then it goes on to the document and
then the window and then again if i
click this again you can see the div 2
event isn't far enough because again
what we've done here is defined that we
only want this event to fire off once
now another common method you likely run
into is the prevent default method now
what this method does is pretty
self-explanatory really it just prevents
any default behavior that might occur on
an element or an event so this is quite
dependent on the type of element
involved and the context of an event so
to see example of the prevent default
method
what i'm going to do is go into the
index.html and i'm just going to change
the button
to an anchor tag
and i'm going to give this a class
of a button
and i'm just going to put in here click
and then
uh we'll go where the styling is for the
button and we'll make this a class
and then what we'll also do is just put
it on a new line so we'll say display
block
because
anchor tags are inline by default
so we'll head into the app.js file and
what also do is just make sure our query
selector here is targeting that class of
button so our anchor tag now and this
event listener here is now the target
and the event and because we've changed
the button to an anchor tag if i click
on this now you can see it's firing off
all the events but they quickly refresh
and the reason it's doing this is
because the default behavior of an
anchor tag is to try and redirect us to
somewhere else and this is what's
causing this quick fire off of all the
events and then a refresh now we can
stop this from happening with the
prevent default method so to do that
we'll go inside
our button here or the class of button
and we'll grab the um
event object
prevent
default
and if i click on the button now you can
see it's showing us the bubbling phase
the content has changed to click that
it's staying there and all this has
happened now is because we apply the
prevent default method onto our anchor
tag so it's no longer trying to direct
us somewhere else now we will see a more
practical example of all the methods we
just learned so the prevent default uh
the stop propagation in part two of the
tutorial where we look at practical
examples and projects but i just wanted
to make you guys aware of these um so
they don't confuse you in that
subsequent video
now the last thing i want to mention in
this tutorial guys is event delegation
now event delegation is one of the most
potent event handling patterns inside
javascript and the dom and what it does
is allows users to append a single event
listener to a parent element that adds
it to all of its present and future
descendants that match that selector now
what we'll do is actually break this
definition down to show you guys exactly
what it means now the first part here
where it says it allows users to append
the single event listener to a parent
element adds it to all of its present
children to find out why this is useful
let's actually just go back a few steps
and see how we get to event delegation
so if we head back into the index.html
file you can see we've got an unordered
list which has a bunch of different
sports inside of it now this honorable
list has an id of sports and then each
of these list items have their own id
which is equivalent to the content that
you see inside of each of the list items
and this is what it looks like in the
console now if i click on one of these
list items you can see it's showing us
in the console that football's click and
it also changes its background to a
light gray again to highlight that has
been clicked and again this is going to
be the same for each individual list
item now to achieve this what we can do
is apply event listeners to each
individual
list item that we have inside our
unordered list so we'll head into the
app.js file and we'll grab the first
list item so we'll say document dot
query selector grab the id of football
add the event list now
and we're going to look out for a
click event
grab a function
inside of the function we'll include the
event object
and then inside of this function
uh what we want to do is uh first just
console log
in
let's say
say football
is clicked
and then the next thing i want to do is
change that background color when we
click on the actual list item so to do
that we're going to first need to create
a constant so we're going to say
call this target and this is just going
to equal e dot target which is that list
item
and i'm going to say if
and the condition we're going to put in
here
is if target
matches
so matches is just a method basically
which essentially checks with the target
which in this case is the list item
matches with our css selector which is
going to be li this is going to return
true and then when it returns through
it's going to change our background
color so after condition we want to
include the code that we want to execute
so we're going to say target
dot
style
dot
background
color
and we'll set that to
light
gray
and if we head into this folders live
server here you can see we have the
exact same layout and what should happen
now if i click on the football list item
the background should change to a color
of light gray and it should also show
here in the console so if i click on
this you can see saying football is
click and then it's changing the
background to light gray because we've
just created an event listener for it um
inside the app.js file
now again if we wanted to do it for all
of these what i need to do is just
duplicate this
four more times
so
instead of football here we have
basketball
and then for the third one we have
boxed
for the fourth one
we have
tennis
and then we'll create one more
for golf
and now all the starter then the console
logs should be working for each of the
list items so we'll start with football
see that's working basketball's working
boxing's working
tennis and golf are also working so
we're getting the exact same thing as
our draft example here
except the text is a little bit
different but again it's the exact same
styling and you can see it's working
perfectly fine now this is great and
works fine there's no real issue with
the code here because we're getting the
exact same result as our draft example
but as you'll learn throughout your code
and journey there are always questions
to ask when you have written out your
code to help improve it so you can ask
yourself things like can we remove some
of this code can we remove some of the
event listeners and still achieve the
same result can this task be done
writing less code instead or can we even
optimize this code and the simple answer
really is that we can we can write less
code here and achieve exactly the same
result using event delegation so the
idea of event delegation is pretty
simple instead of attaching the event
listeners directly to each of the list
items here we can delegate the listening
to the parent which is the ul here which
has the id of sports so that when the li
is clicked the listener of the parent
element catches the bubbling event and
performs our task which change the color
of our background to light gray when we
clicked on one of the boxes and also
showcased some text inside of our
console here so what we're going to do
to achieve this now is go back to the
app.js file and get rid of all this code
here
and then we're first going to grab that
unordered list element which has the id
of sports
so we'll say document dot query selector
and then we'll say
we'll grab the id which is sports
and add the event listener to this
so a similar process it's going to be a
click event
rudolph function which has
the event object inside its parameters
inside of our function here
we want to say
let's console log that bit of text so
we'll say
e dot target
dot get
attribute
method of get attribute and we want to
get the id
and then we want to say plus
we'll put in here is
clicked
so what we're saying here is that when
the target which is our list items has
an id attribute which all of them do
whichever one that we click on will
display that specific sport plus the
extra bit of text here of is clicked so
if i go ahead and click on one of these
now you can see it's saying football is
clicked if i click on tennis you see
tennis is click golf boxing and
basketball so you can see all of these
now are working because we've attached
that one event listener to the parent
element which catches the bubbling event
and then performs our task which we've
written in here now we also want to
change uh the background color when we
click on these so to do that first going
to need to create a variable of um the
target so we're going to say target
it's going to equal e dot
target which is those list items
and then we're going to say
if the target
variable there
matches our css selector which is our li
we're going to want to change the uh
background so say target dot style dot
back
ground
color
to a light gray so again if i click on
one of these now uh we're getting an
error um that's because i spelt
matches
wrong
so again if i click on one of these now
you can see the text will appear in the
console highlighting which one i clicked
and then we also now have the extra
feature of where the background changes
to a light gray for all of our list
items there
now again this brings us back to our
first um part of our definition which
allows users to append a single event
listener to our parent element that adds
it to all of its present children and as
you can see this is clear benefits
ranging from code quality as well as
code maintenance because instead of
having all those lines of code um in the
previous example where we attached an
event listener to each of the list items
we now have it all inside one event
listener here now we've also improved
our performance because having more
events in our code will take up a lot of
memory and using event delegation we're
going to save a ton on memory which
again will vastly improve our
performance inside of our
projects now another crucial benefit of
event delegation is the second part of
our definition here so the first part
was it allows users to append a single
event listener to a parent element that
adds it to all of its present
descendants now the second part of this
definition was that it also adds it to
future descendants that match that
selector so this is actually in regard
to dynamic elements so let's just say we
had an add button here at the end of
this box where it allowed us to add
another sport to our list
so let's actually just manually do this
to show you guys exactly what i mean so
first we're just going to create a
constant
for our um ul which has the idea of
sports so we'll say const say sports
equals document.queryselector
and then we'll just grab the id of
sports again which is that ul
and then what we'll also do is create
another list item
so we'll say const new
sport
equals document
dot create
element
and we'll create another list item
and then what we'll do
is uh
we'll say
new
sport so that variable which is that new
list item
uh we'll give it
uh
in a text
of uh let's say
let's make the sport rugby and then
we'll also give it the uh
id
of rugby so we'll say set attribute
first an id attribute and then we're
gonna have
the uh id
of rugby
and then what we want to do is append
this now to our list so we'll grab
the sports variable which is the ul and
we'll say append
child
and then the chart we want to append is
of course that new sport so let me say
new
sport
so as you can see now rugby has been
added to our list here so if i click on
this it's got the exact same styling and
the output in the console like the rest
of the list items would because we now
have an event listener to the parent
which is the ul and because of event
delegation we've delegated the event to
the parent and as you can see this gives
us the power to dynamically add new list
items and those new list items will
display the same behavior so again
without the magic of event delegation
we'd have to use the method we
previously used we would have to include
event listeners to each individual list
items and that includes any new list
items that might get added on along the
way which will just clog up memory
effect performance and just create too
much unnecessary code so that's going to
be it for this video guys in this video
we're going to be using everything we
learned in part one and applying it to
five different projects ranging from
beginner to master level
so just like in part one guys there's
going to be a few prerequisites in order
to effectively understand the dom and
how it relates to these projects i
highly recommend checking out part one
first as well as also having an existing
knowledge of html and css
now in regards to styling we're not
gonna be focusing too much on it for our
projects because this isn't really the
goal of the course however there will be
substantial css styling involved and
then lastly it's going to be essential
to have familiarity with the
fundamentals of javascript and the
syntax and the code structure because
obviously we're going to be using
javascript in this course all right guys
so our first project for this course is
going to be this beginner friendly quote
generator that houses a quote and then
has a reference by someone famous
underneath it now underneath that
reference of that famous person we have
a button which says new quote and if i
click on this you'll see it'll just
generate us some new quotes by someone
else famous so pretty cool design and
quite simple to create now some of the
key concepts we're going to need for
this project is document.queryselector
add event listener of course the math
object and in a text property so now we
know what we're creating and the key
concept we're going to need let's head
into vs code now and create our quote
generator
all right so we're inside vs code and
you can see we're inside a folder called
master dom manipulation part 2
inside of an index.html file as well as
having a style.css file and a javascript
file for our project one and also have
an image folder which has all of our
images which is just going to be the
background uh image for all of our
projects so the first thing we'll do is
include a link to our style sheet so
we'll go inside here
and we'll grab style.css now the next
thing i'm going to do is go and get a
google font so we'll head over to google
and the global font we're going to be
using for our project is going to be a
roboto regular 400. so we'll just grab
the link here inside google fonts
head back into vs code and then just
paste it underneath the style sheet
there and then just
tab this over so it is looking all neat
and what we'll do as well is just
put a comment here so uh
global
font
links and we'll do the same for the
style sheet
and then lastly what we'll include in
the head tag is just a link to font
awesome so we can grab all of our icons
that we're going to be using throughout
the project so we're heading to our font
awesome cdn here and then we click the
first link so we copy the link tag head
back into vs code and then just paste it
under our google fonts so we'll just say
font
awesome
i think
place that in there
close that off and then let's open this
up with live server so we have our blank
canvas
and we can see all of our work and we'll
split screen this
and just
a bit smaller
so we're ready to start a markup for our
first project so if we take a look at
the original example you can see we have
two sections here so we have our heading
and then we also have the main section
which houses the quote uh the famous
person and the button so
we'll head inside the body
we just put a comment here for
project
one
quote
generator
and
we're going to house this project inside
a div the class of container hit tab
and then again we're going to need a
header so we'll just put another div
here with
a class of header
put in here a h2 and we'll say
java
script
quote
generator so you'll see that there in
live server and then underneath the
header we're gonna have this content
here which has the quote as well as the
name of that specific person who said
the quote and then the button underneath
which will um generate a new quote for
us
so we'll get back into this blank canvas
there we'll go underneath the header and
we'll just create a div with the class
of main content which again is just
going to house everything
scroll down a little bit and then the
first thing we need is the actual text
area so we can just put div
call it text
area
inside of that we want to have a span
which has the class of quote which is
going to be our quote and then i'm going
to paste our quote inside of here which
is the exact same as the original
example and then underneath the text
area div we want to have a div for the
actual um
famous person who said the quote let's
keep it simple and just say person
hit tab
and then this person for this quote is
abraham
lincoln
so we have our quote now as well as
having the person who said the quote and
then of course underneath this
we're going to have the button so we'll
house the button inside of a div with
the class of button area and this is
going to house our button so this button
is going to have an id of
say new
quotes we're going to need to
grab onto this later
and we'll just put in here
text of new
quote
so that's essentially it for our markup
let's head into the style sheet now and
just apply some general styles first
so what you put in here general
styles
so we use the asterisk to grab
everything and we're going to say
margin zero
padding
zero
box size into border box
let's also make sure that the uh font
family for all of our projects is
our lato font
uh we'll just have sans serif as a
backup
and then let's first grab the body
element
because we want to
use display flex to center everything
so we'll say justify content to the
center align items
to the center
let's use the height
and make it
a thousand one hundred viewport heights
which would be the height whole height
of our um window there and then let's
also text the line everything to the
center
and then the next thing i'll do is
include our background image for our
first project which is this sort of
library image here
so to do that we'll grab the background
property url
grab the image folder head inside it and
grab project one
now this is way too big at the moment so
the first thing i want to do is
add a few more bits of styling so no
repeat
uh we want to center
everything on the x and y and then we
want this to cover
the whole body so as you can see now it
looks pretty much exactly the same
as our original example
so that's it for the body there next
thing i want to do now is grab the
container class which houses everything
i'm going to give this a width of
550 pixels
a height of 450 pixels
now the next thing we'll do is just
style our heading which is the
javascript quote generator text there
so we'll grab the header class
and let's uh increase the font size of
this to say about 1.2 rem
and let's give this a border of solid
say about 2 pixels
and make it a nice white color change
the color of the text to white
uh let's make that a bit clearer so
we'll change the background color to uh
a bit of a darker gray
let's also add a bit of padding there
between the text and the border so about
five pixels
and let's make the width of this to be
about say about
eighty percent
set the margin
to uh let's say 20 pixels from top and
bottom and about
and then auto on the left and right so
this is centered
now let's actually make the edges of our
border here a bit more rounder
so we'll use the
border radius method
property
let's
make it about five pixels
i just think that looks a little bit
better so that's it for our heading now
let's grab the uh
main content which is basically just all
of our content here so the um
quote the
person who said the quote and then the
button itself
so this is a class of main
content
so what i want to do is just make the
width of this
100
the height
let's make about 300 pixels
the padding
let's give this a background color of
white
so there's our content
let's also
make the edges more rounded so
say border radius so about 15 pixels
let's uh also add a bit of padding here
between the content
and the edges so we'll say
it's about 50 pixels on the top and
bottom about 40 pixels on the left and
right
uh
next thing i want to do is actually give
this a box shadow so it gives it more of
like a 3d look so let's say zero on the
x and y
let's put about 10 pixels blur so the
box shadows all the way around which i
think looks a lot better there
now let's uh
style the text or the quote so this is
the main content
and the text
area
so let's just give this a font size
about let's say 1.5 ram see what that
looks like
yeah i think that looks pretty good
let's also add a bit of line height here
1.5
give it a bit of breathing room
and uh
yeah i think that looks pretty good
now we want to style the person
who says the quote
so we'll say
main
main content
dot person
and let's increase the uh
size of the text so we'll say font size
let's say about
1.6 rem
yeah looks pretty good
change the color
to red
uh let's
think the original is capitalized so
text decoration
uppercase
so text
transform
uppercase
now of course we want to add a bit of
margin here so let's say margin
top it's about 20 pixels
so i think that's starting to look a lot
like the original
as you can see there
now let's uh
let's now start the button
so
we'll grab the uh
button
area
which uh houses the button
and we'll grab the actual button itself
uh so um let's
change the background color
to that dark gray
let's change the color of the text so we
can see it
to white
and let's uh increase the font size of
this
to say 1.2 rem
let's actually make that a bit bigger
1.3
and then let's add a bit padding of
course so i'll say 10 pixels on the top
bottom
about 15 pixels on the left and right
let's also add a bit of margin to the
top of this to separate it from that
text there
margin top let's say about
20 pixels
and then let's make it rounded on the
edges so border radius
let's say about five pixels
so the last thing i want to do here is
that when we click on this
um you can see in the original when we
click on this it actually uh changes
color
so we need to change its active state
so we'll just grab this
and let's grab the active
pseudo class
and we'll say the background
color let's make it a light
blue so that's pretty much it for the
styling all we need to do now is start
applying some logic to this so we can
generate new quotes when we click on
this new quote button so the first thing
we're going to need to do is head into
the index.html
file and just go underneath all this
content here and just put
a comment for scripts because this is
where we're gonna be placing all of our
scripts
and then we're just gonna link to that
script file
or our first script file so we'll sort
it to
it's called project
one dot js
so we've linked it to our javascript
file so we'll head into that the first
thing we're going to need to do is just
create some variables so we're in the
variable for our button here as well as
the quote and the person that said the
quote
so we'll just put a comment here saying
variables and we'll say
let btn equal
document dot query selector
and then we'll select the um
button which has an id of new
quote so we've stored our button inside
that variable there we'll create another
variable now for our
quote itself so we'll just call this
quote
we'll set this to document.queryselector
and i believe this has a class of
quote
close that off so now we've stored the
span which has the quote inside of it
inside that variable there
and then lastly we're going to need one
more for the person
and we'll say document dot
query selector
and this has a class of
person so we've got our three variables
there now the next thing we're going to
need is array for all of our quotes so
we'll call this array uh let's call it
quotes now i'm going to copy and paste
all the quotes i used in the original
example um which i just found on the
internet i'm not really sure if they
those individuals actually said those
quotes if you guys want to use different
quotes and people for your
quote generator feel free to do so so
i'm just going to paste those in there
so there's all our quotes there which i
think is a total of 10 quotes so the
next thing we're going to do here is now
apply an event listener to our button
here so when we click on this button of
new quote it will generate a new quote
for us so one of these quotes by one of
these individuals
so we'll go underneath the array and
we'll say
btn.ad event listener and we're going to
look out for a click event
and we're going to have a function
now inside of our function here we're
first going to need to create a variable
which houses a basic math equation which
is essentially just going to involve the
built-in math object and a couple of its
methods
so let's call this variable let's call
it let random now as i just mentioned
javascript has that built in math object
and this object has several methods now
the two that we're going to be using in
this equation are math.floor and
math.random now i will go over the
equation again but i first just going to
create it quickly because it's just a
bit easier to explain so let random is
going to equal math
dot floor and then inside of this method
here we're going to have
math again dot random
and we're going to times this by
our
quotes array dot length
which is essentially just all the quotes
in our array so again how this equation
is working is that the math.random times
the quotes dot length will generate a
number between zero and the total number
of quotes inside of our quote array now
because math.random doesn't actually
generate a whole number we need to wrap
this equation in math.floor or the floor
method which essentially just rounds a
number downwards to the nearest integer
and what this will do now is allow us to
access our properties inside of our
array which are the variables of quote
and person so that's essentially how
this variable and this math equation is
working here now this equation will
randomize through our quotes array
however we need to display the quote and
person inside of our array to a string
format so to do that we'll go underneath
the variable here and we'll grab
let's grab
uh quote first
and we need to change the inner
text
and then we're going to set this to
equal
the quotes
array
square brackets to turn it into a string
format and we'll put in the random
variable and we'll say
dot
quote
and then we'll do the exact same thing
but we'll do it for
person
so i'll just change this to person and
this now should randomize through our
quotes array and display new quotes said
by different people so if we go to the
button and we click on the button it's
generated us new quotes and it's also
giving us different people who have said
those quotes
and that is our first project completed
so a pretty cool project and pretty
straightforward to create all right guys
so the next project this course is the
beginner plus project which is a modal
now a motor is essentially just a ui
element that appears in the foreground
of a website and they're usually
triggered by the user allowing them to
view more information or complete an
action without having to navigate to
another url in our case it's just going
to show more information so we have our
ui element here in the foreground and
then if i click on this you can see
another box animates downwards the rest
of the content darkens so it puts a lot
more focus in the box in the middle and
that's essentially what our model is
here now of course in this box you'd
likely have more information but i just
wanted to keep it simple uh for this
example
now the key concepts we're going to need
for this project switched up a little
bit we're going to be using the
document.elementbyid
of course the ad event listener method
the e.target and we're going to be using
css styling throughout javascript and
we're also going to include some css
animation in this project so let's head
into vs code now and create our model
all right guys so we're back inside our
master dom manipulation part two folder
and as you can see we've got our blank
canvas there open up in live server so
the first thing we're going to need uh
for our markup it's just gonna be the
modal open button so we'll just put a
comment in here model
open
button
which is the button if we take a look at
the original example uh this button here
which is going to trigger our model so
we're just going to have a button this
is going to have an id of
open
btn because we're going to be using a
element by id for this example
and we're just going to put a paragraph
tag in here and this is just going to
have the text of
where's uh
model
so that's it for the open button now the
next thing we're gonna need is the
actual model itself so i'm just gonna
put a comment in here say modal and
modal
background
so we're going to have a div
with the id of
modal
container
inside of that we're going to have our
div with the id of modal which is going
to be our modal
paragraph tag inside of that which is
going to say here
i
am and then underneath that we're going
to have another div which is going to be
our close button so we're just going to
have
let's say div we'll give this an id of
close
btn
and to create that x we're just going to
be using a html entity so it's going to
be an ampersand times
semicolon and that's going to be that
cross that you can see there so that's
all we're going to need for the markup
the next thing i want to do is
just quickly
uh comment out this script for project
one but duplicate this and then
link it to project two so if i actually
open this up you can see i've created
another um js file which is project two
just close that back up so the next
thing i want to do now is just apply
some styling so we're heading inside the
style shape and the first thing i'm
gonna do is get that background image
that you see here in the original
example
so we're just going to grab the body and
we're going to change the background
to url
and this is going to be the image folder
project two
and then apply those same rules that we
did in the previous example so no repeat
center
center and then we're gonna have cover
so we'll be able to see the image there
and then to make it the whole heart of
the browser should change the height to
100 viewport heights
so there's our image now the next thing
i want to do is actually position this
relative because i want to initially
position our button here a little bit
further down and slightly to the right
just like it is in our example here
so
what we're going to do is now grab that
button
which has the id of open
button i'm just going to open our module
set the position of this to be absolute
so we can now position this anywhere
um on our browser there i'm going to say
top
say
about 70
and then let's also
from the left
10
now let's start giving this a bit of
styling so it looks a little bit better
uh we'll give this a width of
350 pixels
make it a bit bigger
and we'll also give it a height
let's set about 80 pixels
uh let's make the font size a bit bigger
let's say about two ram see what that
looks like
yeah it looks pretty good and
let's
make the background
transparent just like the original
change the color of the text
to white so we can see it
um let's also
change the color of the border
uh
let's make it solid two pixels
white
now let's also
uh let's add a bit of uh border radius
to the edges
just because i think it looks a lot
neater when the edges are rounded uh so
let's say about 10 pixels
and maybe a bit padding
it's also about five pixels there
that looks pretty good let's also
use our good friend box shadow
give it that nice 3d effect
so we say zero on the x and y but three
pixels blur so it goes all the way
around
uh let's make it black
yeah looks good
um
now
if we take a look at the original you
can see
there's an effect on there so we need to
add a transition
uh
transition say about
five seconds
uh so that's pretty much it for that
styling the next thing i want to do
obviously is add a bit of a hover effect
so we'll just grab this
so we'll just grab
this and
paste it in here over effect
we'll hover class and we'll change the
background color
uh
let me choose the background
color to
white and then the text
to
uh black
so there's that effect which is the
exact same
as our original there
that looks pretty good now the next
thing i want to do is style our model
here which is going to be that box that
um shows up when we click on this button
here
so uh has the class of
modal
and then we'll change the background
color of this to be white
we'll
set the position of this
to be
absolute
then we'll say
scroll down so you can see we'll say top
50
left
50
and then transform
translate
and we'll say uh
negative 50
and negative 50 which would basically
just uh center this in the middle so
this is just another way to actually
center content instead of using flexbox
or css grid now
i want this to be a bit bigger so we'll
say width so 200 pixels
height
let's say 100 pixels
um give it a bit of padding
on the top and bottom and then 20 on the
left and right
uh the old classic border radius
give it
rounded edges
and then uh the font size let's make
this a bit bigger
let's say 1.5 rim now this is actually
not going to display at the moment but i
just want to create the styling here um
so we don't have to do it afterwards now
this model is actually wrapped inside of
the modal container which we're going to
be displaying as none initially because
we don't actually want this to show but
i just wanted to start everything first
before i make this sort of disappear
initially
now the next thing i want to do is if we
take a look at the original example
you can see that the text is on the left
and the x is on the right so to do that
we're going to be using
display
flex
so we have like a nested flexbox
and then we'll just say justify
content
space
between
and then we'll align the items
vertically to the center
now if we take a look again at the
previous example click off this you can
see this actually animates from the top
so we're going to be using keyframes uh
to do this
so
i'm going to create an animation um
say animation animation
name we're going to call this animate
modal
and then we want the animation
duration which is going to be 0.4
seconds we'll create this animation
right at the end but i just wanted to
again put all the styling on this modal
uh first before we get to that so the
next thing i'm going to do is style the
cross here
so this has a class
of not class rated id of
closed btn
font size
um
let's make this about
three rem
so it's nice and big
and then let's apply a hover to this so
when we hover over it it turns red so
close btn
um let's make it also a cursor pointer
uh font
size
let's also make sure this is three rem
and then change the color
to a red color so say f
0 0
0.
so there's our cross there now just to
quickly mention guys this is the same
style sheet we were using
in the previous project so it has those
general styles there
just in case that confused some people
but anyway uh we've done the modal now
so what we need to do is actually grab
the modal container and actually
initially make this disappear so
we'll grab the modal
container
and we'll display this as none
comment this out so we can still see it
but what i want to do is actually
position this
to fixed
so it's right at the top there and we'll
say top
zero
and then
left
zero
width
one hundred
percent and then the height
to also be
100
and then have the z index here
let's have this at one so it's above
everything
so let's just uncomment this now so we
can no longer see it so that's nearly it
for the styling um there's still some
styling in regards to the animation
which we can do in just a moment but
let's first start applying some
javascript to this so we're heading to
the project 2.js file and the first
thing we're going to need to do is just
create some variables so one for the
open button one for the modal container
and then one for the close button so
we'll just put in here
comment for variables
we'll say let open
vtn equal
document.getelementbyid which you're
going to be using for this example
and this has an id of
open
vtn
and then we'll create another one for
the
modal container so we'll say modal
container equals document
dot
get element by id
and this has an id of modal
container
and then one more for the
close button
so close btn
equals
document dot
get element
iid
and this has an idea of
close
btn so that's it for the variables the
next thing i want to do is now start
writing out our of event listeners so
we'll just put in here event
listeners
so the first one we're going to apply it
to
is the uh open btn variable so the open
button so we'll say open btn so add
event listener
look out for a click event
function
and inside of this function we're going
to be using css styling so we're going
to grab the modal container
and we're going to grab the style
attribute and then inside the star we're
going to be using the display property
set this equal to block
because if we take a look at the
style.css you can see we have this as
displayed as none now we wanted to
display it as block when we click on the
open button which is this button here
so if i click on this now it should show
us our model
as you can see it's popping up in the
center there so this event listener is
working now we can't actually click off
of this model so we can't really close
it we're going to need a couple more
event listeners so we'll do one for the
close button there
so we'll say close btn
add event list now
look out for a click event
function
and inside of this function we'll apply
the same sort of styling so we'll say
mode or container
dot style
display attribute
display property
and then we'll set this to none so we'll
just refer back to none so now we've got
two event listeners here we've got our
open button and then for our close
button there if we click on this this
should get rid of our model and as you
can see that's working now now if we
take a look at the actual original
example if we click on this and we show
our model it closes if we click on the
close button here but if we also click
outside anywhere of our model here you
can see it closes the modal tube so i
want to add another event listener so we
can do that so we actually apply this to
the window object so this is actually
the highest object in the dom tree this
goes above the document
so
we'll say
look out for a click event
function again we'll insert the event
object in there
and then inside of the function itself
we're going to use an if statement
so we're going to say if e dot target if
you guys remember back to the um part 1
of this course the event.target
essentially just returns the element
that triggers the event which in this
case is going to be our window so we're
going to say if e.target is equal to
modal container we're going to grab the
modal container use the same
style attribute display property
i'm going to equal this
to
none so again what this should do now is
when we click on this to activate our
modal so we can see it on the screen we
should be able to click anywhere outside
of this module and the model will
disappear so as you can see that's
working if i click up here disappears
click up there disappears and if we also
click on the close button it will
disappear so that's pretty much it for
the javascript
pretty simple design really and quite
simple to create the next thing i'll do
is just apply some style into the module
and the modal container because if i
click on this you can see that the
background darkens around the modal as
well as the modal smoothly
animating from the top of the browser
there do that we'll head back inside our
star.css and to create that nice
animation you can see we've got
animation name and the animation
duration we're going to be using
keyframes so we'll just say
a comment here first modal animation
section
we'll say the
at keyframes rule
use the name which is animate
modal
is that oh it's not got a capital m
what you want to say is just use the
from n2
so from
when i say top
negative 300 pixels
set the opacity to zero so we can't see
it
and then two
let's say from the top
fifty percent
and then the opacity
to one
so as you can see when we type in this
keyframe out
the animation is working so i'm just
going to click off this
click on our open button and you can see
now the modal is animating exactly the
same as the original
and lastly i just want to create this
this dark background when the motor
appears so to do that
we're going to go
in the modal container here or the id of
a motor container
add a background color
rgba
we'll say zero for red zero for green
zero for blue and then for the alpha
which is the opacity we'll say point two
and as you can see it just gives the
modal container and which is wrapping
around the model a nice uh dark effect
which just gives us a good emphasis on
the model itself this now looks exactly
like our original example it looks
pretty good
so our third project is going to be an
accordion now what an accordion does is
let you squeeze in a lot of content into
a small space and a web page and a
classic example is like one in our
project here which is an faq or
frequently asked question which you'll
most likely see in utilized in many
websites so as you can see here we have
a couple of questions just some random
questions like a return policy or where
they're located and if i click on one of
these you'll see it open up and show us
more content which again is a really
useful project to learn as you're most
likely going to be utilizing this type
of design in many of your own projects
now the key concepts we're going to need
in this tutorial are document dot get
element by class name this time of
course the advert listener the for loop
but this keyword on the classlist and
toggle method so let's head into vs code
now and create our accordion
all right guys so the first thing i'm
going to need to do is create the markup
for the accordion so we're going to have
a
class of accordion which basically just
houses everything or the accordion then
i'm gonna have a
h2
the class of uh say accordion
title
and we'll say frequently
asked
questions and underneath that we're
going to have several containers which
is going to house the question and the
answer and you guys can put as many of
these containers as you like but i'm
just going to use three which is the
exact same as our draft example so we're
going to create that class of content
container and this is also going to be
the class that we link to our javascript
so we can show that extra content
so inside of these we're going to have
class of question
so the question first question is what
is the return
policy
and then we're gonna have
the class of answer
which is just going to be some dummy
text
and then we'll just duplicate this
container two more times again you guys
can include more if you like
but we're just going to stay the same as
the draft
example
so that's essentially it for the markup
let's head into the style sheet now and
just apply some uh styling to this now
the first thing we're going to do
is just grab the body
and include our background image
so this can have a url image folder
project three
and then a few more
bits of styling so no repeat center on
the x and y
and then cover
so we can see the whole image
make this the whole height of the
browser
and then use flexbox again
to center our content
and then align items to the center
so that's all we need for the body let's
start applying some styles to the
accordion
which pretty much just houses everything
we're going to give this a width of 65
and
background color
let's give it a white background color
add a bit of padding
so let's say about
30 pixels all the way around
and then of course a good friend border
radius
just to make the edges more rounded so
so we'll apply 30 pixels there
now for the title itself
uh we'll go and give that a bit of
styling
this has the
accordion title styling scroll down so
you guys can see a bit clearer
we'll just add some margin bottom
of 30 pixels to separate from the rest
of the content and then
text the line to the center
so it's centered
there
now let's apply some style into our
questions there
so
grab the accordion
content
container
and then grab the question
or class of question
and let's give this some padding too so
18 pixels on top and bottom zero pixels
on the left and right
and let's
also
uh increase the font size a little bit
22 pixels
set the cursor to a pointer and then
let's add a border bottom here one pixel
solid
black
so it has a line underneath the
questions just so it's a bit clearer to
see the separation between that and the
content and then the next thing we need
to do here is set position
of relative that's because we're going
to be positioning the open and close
sections that you see here in the
original example absolute to our
question class
so that's what we're going to go ahead
and do now so we'll grab the accordion
class
content container
question class and we're going to be
using the pseudo element of after
and we'll go inside this and we'll grab
the content
property
and use a plus sign in there
and then we'll position this
absolute
and then from the right
we'll say about negative five pixels
so i think that looks pretty good there
let's now focus on this content here so
the dummy text
so
we'll go underneath
this bit here
grab the accordion class
grab the content container and then
we'll grab the answer class which is the
dummy text
and we'll add a bit of padding
top
of 15 pixels
just so it separates it from the ball
the bottom there
will increase the font size of this
it's about 22 pixels as well
and then let's add a bit of line height
let's say 1.5
between the content
and then make sure the width of this
is a hundred percent
now of course we want this content to be
hidden initially like it is in the
original example so to do that what
we're going to need to do is change the
height of our answer class there to zero
pixels now if you take a look at the
browser you can see that all of the
content is overflowing it's doing
exactly what we wanted to do by setting
the height to zero pixels but of course
all this content here we want it to be
hidden so what we can do to hide that is
just use the overflow property and set
that to hidden
and as you can see all of that content
isn't showing
now one last thing i want to do in here
is that if we take a look at the
original example we open this up you see
it's nice and smooth so to do that
we're gonna need to set the transition
of this to be
about 0.5
seconds so that when we do apply the
javascript and we click on these it'll
be nice and smooth so that's almost it
for the styling we're going to need a
few more bits in just a moment but first
we need to create the javascript to get
this all working so we'll head into the
javascript file there and the first
thing i'm going to do is just create a
variable i'm just going to put a comment
here variable
and this variable is
going to be called uh accordion and
we're going to be using the document
dot get element by class name
so this is going to select all the
elements with this class name and we
want to select the
content
container classes
which houses the question and the answer
now we're going to want to access all of
these classes and to do that we're going
to need a for loop
so we're just going to put in
4
we're going to have a variable of i
equals 0.
and then we're going to say i
is less than the accordion
dot
length and if it is less than the
accordion.length which it will be we
want to increment this
our variable by one
then inside of this for loop
because we're essentially selecting all
of the
classes of content container we want to
apply an event list now on each of these
so we'll grab the accordion and then
grab the
variable of i inside of our for loop
and then add an event listener here
in where we want
a click event so on each of the content
containers we want to click event
then we're going to include a function
and then inside of this function what we
want to do is reference the object which
the function is a property or in other
words reference the object that is
currently calling the function which in
this case is our accordion and we could
do that by using the this keyword and
then using this we can insert a class of
active on all of those reference points
which are essentially our content
containers so we'll say
class
list
dot toggle which is just another method
which i actually forgot to mention in
part one but what this essentially does
is just toggle between adding and
removing a class name for an element
with javascript and the class that we
want to toggle is of course the one i
just mentioned so we want to call this
class active which i'll show you guys in
a minute why we need to do this
so what we've done here is store all our
elements with a class of content
container inside of this variable of
accordion
we then loop through this variable
and this has allowed us to add an event
listener to all of our content container
classes and inside of the function we
then reference this object that is
calling the function i.e our accordion
variable and then added the toggle
method to either add or remove the class
of active so all we need to do now is
head back into our css and apply the
styles to our active class we created
inside of this function so we'll head
back to star.css again
and then what we'll do should put a
comment here
and say java
script
styling link
go underneath here and then just grab
the class of accordion grab the content
container class select the active class
we created inside of our javascript
and then grab the answer
or the class of answer which is
all of that content which has a dummy
text inside of it
and then just set a height of this to be
150 pixels
so what this should do now is using the
javascript we just created
toggle the class of answer so that when
we click on any of the questions the
height of the answer container will be
150 pixels instead of zero pixels and
then show us all that content so if i
click on this you can see now it's open
up and showing us all that content so
you can see that the javascript is
working as well as the styling we just
created with the active class we just
inserted with the active class so just a
few little bits here now to finish off
so we'll just grab the accordion
grab the content container grab the
active class again
and we'll grab the question so i just
want to change some style into the
question when this is clicked
so uh let's
affect the font size that's a little bit
smaller so say about 18 pixels and we
want this to be smooth so we'll just put
a transition of
0.5 seconds
so as you can see this shrinks down when
we click on this um just so it puts more
emphasis on the content there
and then lastly let's change the open
button to
a closed section when we click on it
just like it does in the original
example here as you can see there
so
let's go underneath this
grab the accordion class again
content
container
dot active
and dot question
after pseudo-element
change the content
to a dash
let's also increase the font size of
this
to 30 pixels
let's give it a nice transition
by five seconds
and as you can see there it's all
working perfectly fine the javascripts
are working as well as the styling
so that's going to be it for this
project another really useful project to
learn as you'll most likely run into
needing something of this project's
nature
so for our fourth project we're going to
be up in the ante a little bit and
create this pretty cool stopwatch which
as you can see here we have a play and
also a reset button if i hit the play
button you'll see it transform to a
pause button as the stopwatch is
starting
if i pause it it will pause on that
number and then i can also reset this if
i want to so a pretty cool design and
we're going to be implementing much more
javascript for this project
some of the key concepts we're going to
need for this project are
document.queryselector
document.elementbyd add event listener
if statements the tostring method the
set interval method and inner html
so now we know the project and the key
concept we're going to need for the
project let's head into vs code now and
create our stopwatch
all right guys so inside our index.html
file the first thing we'll do is just
create a div with the class of container
and inside of that div we're going to
house another div which is gonna have an
id of
timer and inside of this we're just
gonna display our timer then underneath
that we're gonna have our buttons so
we're gonna have a div with a class of
buttons
and then we'll have
the start stop button and this is going
to have initially when we're first
showing this going to have an icon
and this is going to have a class of
fa
solid
fa
play
and we're also going to give this an id
of play
and then we'll just duplicate this for
the reset button
reset vtn
and this is gonna have an id of reset
and instead of
play it's gonna have
arrow
dash row
tate
dash left
so that's all we're gonna need for our
markup let's head into star.css and just
apply some styling here
so
first thing we're gonna have is the body
we're gonna include our background image
just like in the previous
examples but first let's just make the
height 100 viewport heights
background
url
img
project 4
and of course some of that classic
styling so no repeat
center
center
cover
so we can see the whole image
so there's our guy there
and then we want to position everything
in the center so let's display this as
flex justify
content center
align items to the center
now let's grab the container which
houses everything
and this is going to have a width of
60 percent
a height of
250 pixels
background
color is gonna be
white
let's give it that nice
border radius
30 pixels and then let's just give this
a bit of shadow so zero on the x and y
and then
three pixels blur so it's all the way
around now the next thing i'm going to
do is style the timer here so
this is an id of timer
set the width of this
to be 100
font size
uh let's make it
72 pixels so nice and big text align
this to the center give it a bit of
margin so
zero on top and bottom auto on the left
and right and then let's also give this
a bit of padding top let's say about say
35 pixels
just to push it down a little bit
now as for the buttons themselves
we'll grab the button we'll grab the
buttons class which houses the buttons
we'll text align this to the center
and then
let's give it a bit of margin on the top
let's say about 40 pixels
and then let's style the buttons here so
so um
let's give a bit of margin between them
so they're not like squished up next to
each other so let's say zero on the top
and bottom about 10 pixels on the left
and right
giving that space uh let's also remove
the border
both of them
and then let's style the actual icons so
button i
say font size
let's say about two ram
padding
so about
10 pixels
and then let's
change the color
to
white
now we can't actually see those really
clearly so let's grab the ids of each of
those so we've got one for play
duplicate that one for
pause
which we'll create later
and then one before reset
now for play this is just gonna have a
background color of green
for
reset
this is gonna have that background color
of red
and then for pause it's gonna have a
background color of orange
and that gives them their background
color now the buttons here actually
aren't the same size so
let's just quickly make these the same
size so we'll say about 50 pixels
yeah that looks a lot better so that's
pretty much it for styling let's head
into the project 4.js file now and start
adding some functionality to our
stopwatch here all right guys so the
first thing we need to do is just create
some variables for our buttons so
just going to put here
variables for buttons
and we're going to say const
start
stop
btn
equals document
dot query selector and then we're just
going to select the id of start
stop
btn and then we're going to have one
more for our reset so
reset btn
equals
document.queryselector
and this has the id of
reset
btn
so there's the variables for our buttons
the next thing i'll do now is just
define a few variables to hold time
values
so
um
put a comment here again
time values
so we'll say let
seconds
equal zero
let
minutes
also equal
zero
and then let
hours
equal zero
so that's all the variables we're going
to need at the moment the next thing i
want to do is actually create our
stopwatch function which is going to
determine when our stopwatch needs to
increment to the next number ie seconds
minutes or hours as well as displaying
that value in the ui
so we'll just put in here uh
stop
watch
function
and then we'll just say function
we'll call this stop
watch so firstly what we want to do when
we invoke this function is actually
increment the seconds so when this fires
off when we press the play button the
seconds will start to increment so we'll
just say seconds
plus plus now of course if we leave it
like this it's just going to increment
the seconds it's not going to jump to
the next value so if we wanted to
increment when it gets to the minutes
and the hours what we're going to need
to do is just create an if statement and
then we're gonna say seconds divided by
60 which is the amount of seconds
is equal to
one
we then want seconds
to jump to zero
and then we want the minutes
to increment so what we're saying here
is that once this reaches 60 our seconds
will restart and then the minutes will
start incrementing so that's how we
increment the next value now of course
we haven't just got minutes we've also
got hours so we need to include that as
well
so we'll apply the same logic here so
minutes divided by 60 is equal to 1. the
condition we want is that minutes
let's back to zero and then the hours
increment now what we need to do from
here is actually create a variable to
display this if statement in the browser
so our stopwatch will actually increment
otherwise the numbers will just stay
static the way they are now so to do
that we're just going to need to go
underneath this if statement here and
say
let's say let
display
timer equal document dot get element by
id we're going to get the id of timer
and we're going to change the inner text
just scroll down a bit so you guys can
see that
and we're going to set this to
equal
hours
plus uh
colon
plus
minutes
plus a
colon again
and then finally seconds
close that off so what we're doing with
this variable is just making sure that
when our if statements here are working
we want it to be displayed in the
browser so the way we can display that
and check that out is we'll just grab
the window object and then we're going
to grab the set interval function which
is basically just a method that calls a
function at specified interval and the
function of course that we want is going
to be our stopwatch and this interval
takes in two parameters so first the
function and then the amount of time and
we're gonna be putting a thousand which
is a thousand milliseconds
so we'll say
stopwatch
and then time of a thousand and if we
take a look at the browser now you can
see that it's beginning to increment
and then if we just make this a bit
quicker so we'll lower down to one
you can see that the minutes now is also
incrementing
and then if we just wait a little bit
longer it should jump to the hours
and as you can see the hours now is also
incremented when it gets to that 60 so
i'm just going to put this back to a
thousand and then comment it out now of
course as you've just seen there when
this function fires off the lead in zero
disappears and if you take a look at our
demo example here and we play this you
can see that it starts incrementing as
it should but the leading zero is still
there now to fix this what we're going
to do is actually create a couple more
variables so we'll go underneath these
variables here and then create variables
for that leading zero so say variables
for leading
zero
so we'll say let
leading
seconds
equal
zero
duplicate this
a few more times
let
leading minutes
equal zero
and then obviously hours
now what we need to do is go back inside
our stopwatch function here go
underneath uh this if statement here and
then create
some conditionals to include that
leading zero if our seconds minutes and
hours is only one digit so we'll say if
seconds
is less than 10
we want to grab the
leading
seconds
and then set this to
that leading zero
which is a string value but we also want
to make this a string value so we'll say
uh two string but we also want to make
this a string value so we'll apply the
two string
method which will turn this
all into a string else we'll just make
sure that else we'll just leave the
leading
seconds to equal
the
normal seconds variable
so of course we want to create
two more
for
minutes and hours so we'll say this one
is for minutes
and
leading minutes
hours
hours
and of course we're also going to have
to change
uh the variable here too so we'll say
leading
hours
leading
minutes
and leading
seconds
so again what we're doing here with the
if statements is making sure that our
leading zero will show if our stopwatch
is only showing one digit and as we just
seen when we invoke the function here
with the set interval that lead in zero
will disappear but because of the
statements we've just created here and
this variable which will display in our
browser if i uncomment our set interval
here it should start incrementing with
that latent zero so i'll uncomment this
out
and as you can see now it's incrementing
with that leading zero and if i just
speed it up it should also apply to the
seconds minutes and hours
as you can see it's working in the
minutes and then if we just wait a
little bit longer again for the hours
the leading zero should still stay there
and as you can see it's working exactly
the way it should so i'll just put this
back to a thousand
and just comment that out
now we're actually invoking this
stopwatch when the browser loads because
we're immediately invoking it through
the window object and our set interval
function but of course we want to have
more power than this and what we want to
do is actually add functionality to our
buttons so what we're going to need to
do
now is actually create a few variables
to hold the set interval function as
well as containing the status of our
stopwatch and which i'll show you guys
exactly what i mean so let's create
those two variables we'll actually
create them up here
so
variables
for
set interval
and
timer
status
so we'll say let
timer
interval
equal
null
just for the time being because we want
to choose when we want the stopwatch to
run not when the page loads
and then of course create another
variable for
our timer status
i'm going to set this equal to a string
value
of stop we now need to use these
variables and apply it to our start stop
button variable there so we'll just go
underneath here and then we'll grab that
start stop button
add the event listener we're going to
look out for a click event we'll grab
the function
inside this function is going to be
where we use those variables we just
created so we're going to say if
timer status
is equal to
stopped
we then want to grab that timer interval
variable and set it to
our actual
set interval function there
paste that in there close that off
we then actually want to change our
button to switch from a play button to
that pause button like it does in the uh
demo example so we'll say document
dot get element iid
grab the
start
stop
id there
and then grab inner html
set that to
backticks and then we are going to grab
the icon
this has got a class of
uh
fa
solid
fa
pause
and then we want to actually include the
id
and which gives it that color of orange
and this has the id of
pause
and then we'll close this off and then
we also want to change the value of our
status
so we're going to grab the timer status
and set this equal to
started
else
if the stopwatch is now running we also
want that functionality of where we can
pause the timer so to do that we need to
grab the window object again grab the
clear
interval function and what this will do
is actually stop our timer and then
insert us
time our interval
variable which is in reference to our
timer variable there close that off
and then of course when this statement
rings true we also want to change our
pause button back to our play button so
we're going to say document
dot get element by id
grab that start
stop btn
id again and then change the inner html
this is going to equal
another icon to i
dot class
equals f a dash solid
f a dash play
and then we also want to grab the id
of play so it has that
green background color close this off
and then again obviously change the
timer status
back to stopped so what we've done here
inside this function was just checking
if the timer status is equal to stopped
the timer will start
and the play button will also change to
a pause button
as well as the time of status changing
to started
else we click the pause button the time
will stop with our clear interval
function there and the pause button will
revert back to our play button as well
as the timer status we'll change back to
stopped
and this now should complete the
functionality for playing and stopping
our timer so if we go ahead and test
this
you can see it's changing to a pause
button and our time is starting to
increment if i press the pause button
again it will stop the timer and our
button revert back to the play button so
as you can see our function's working
perfectly fine there now we're almost
done we just need to add an event
listener to our reset button here so
we're going to need this event listener
here grab the reset button
variable add an event list now look out
for a
click event grab the function
keyword inside of this function scroll
down a bit so you guys can see we want
to grab the window object again clear
the interval so it stops and then
reference that timer interval and then
what we want when we click on this is
grab the seconds
this is going to equal
zero duplicate this
two more times the same for the minutes
and then same for the hours and then
again we want this to actually display
in the browser
so we'll say document
dot
get element by id we want to grab the
timer and then grab
inner html and then set this to the base
of zero zero for the hours minutes and
then for the seconds so with this event
listener we just created here for our
reset button inside of the function
we're again stopping our timer interval
using the clear interval method which is
essentially just a method which clears
the time i set out with a set interval
method now this of course is referencing
this set interval here so again this
will stop our stopwatch just like it
does in the else statement that we've
done here now of course we don't just
want to stop the timer we actually want
to reset it so we revert all of our
seconds minutes and hours back to zero
which we've done here just by changing
the values back to zero and then of
course we want this actually outputted
into the browser so we use the
document.getelementbyid grab the timer
and change the inner html to zero on the
minutes hours and seconds so this now
should actually reset our stopwatch to
zero so if we go ahead and test this out
press the play button so it starts
incrementing and it also reverts to a
pause we'll pause this reverts back to
the play button and our timer stops and
then now if i click this reset button it
should reset our timer and as you can
see our stopwatch is working with full
functionality and this now concludes our
fourth project so quite a bit more
javascript to take in for this project
however once it's understood it's
actually quite a fun exercise to create
alright guys so for our master level
project we're going to be creating a
to-do list and how this to-do list works
is that we simply enter a task inside
the input tab here and then we enter
that task with our add button and what
this will do is add that task underneath
our tab here and when that happens we
get some extra functionality so let's go
ahead and see what that looks like so
let's just enter a task here let's say
collect
shopping
we'll enter that task and as you can see
that task is added underneath and as
well as that we've got some extra
functionality so we've got this orange
box here and we've also got this trash
can now what this orange box does is
that if we complete the task and we
click on this it'll put a line through
it
and if we want to get rid of the task
completely we'll just click the trash
can as you can see it will delete that
from the actual task list now of course
this isn't the prettiest to-do list but
again this isn't really the objective of
this project so feel free to style it
however you like when you guys are
creating yours now this project is
actually going to include quite a lot of
what we learned in part one so i hope
you guys are paying attention so far our
master level project project five the
to-do list these are the key concepts
we're going to need for the project so
we're going to be using
document.elementby d of course again
we're going to be using the event
listener e.target we're going to be
using the penchal method the create
element method the parent element method
as well as the remove and the
classlist.add method so quite a lot of
the concepts we learned in part one so
let's head into vs code now and create
our to-do list
so the first thing we need to do is
create our markup for our to-do list so
we're going to wrap this in a div the
class of container and then we're going
to have a div which houses the input and
the button so we're going to call this
oh we're going to give this an id of
add the task
container
inside of that we're going to have our
input should be the type of text
we're going to give it a placeholder
value
of enter
task
which is just going to be that text
inside of the input and then we're going
to give us an id
of
input
task because we're going to need to grab
onto this to give it an event list line
in the javascript
and then we'll go underneath this and
create our button this button is going
to have an id of
add task because we're going to need to
grab onto this as well we're going to
have an icon with a class of
fa
solid dot
fa plus and there's our input and our
button there and then we'll go outside
of this container and we're gonna have
an id which is gonna be a container for
all of the tasks when we do add them to
our to-do list
so we're just going to give this an id
of
task container
and that's all we're going to need for
the markup let's head into the style
sheet now and give this some styling so
the first thing we're going to want to
do so the first i'm going to do in here
is just grab the body give this a height
of 100 viewport heights and then give it
that background
image
which is going to be an image folder
and it's for project 5. then some extra
style in here
just the same as the others
now we want to align all of the content
in the middle so we're using flexbox
items to the center
so that'll center our content
let's now give some styling to the um
add task container so it's got the id of
add
task
container
this is going to have a width of say 350
pixels
some padding
say 20 pixels on the top and bottom and
10 pixels on the left and right
and give it some background
color of white
and then
our trusty friend border radius just to
give it those rounded edges
and then give it some box shadow because
always looks good with a bit of box
shadow
and then we're going to also need to
display this as flex because we want to
apply some flex rules to the input and
the button there
so let's go ahead and do that let's
go and grab the input
give this a flex of five so it takes up
most of the space
uh
give it some margin
to the right
so it's a bit space between that and the
button so we'll say about
say about 10 pixels
give it the border radius
for those rounded edges
and then font size let's make this a bit
bigger so let's say 1.2 rem
and then let's also give it some padding
so about
five pixels see what that looks like
yeah looks pretty good
and then for the button itself
this has the id of add
task
say font size for this because it's
saying icon we increase the size with
the font size property
say 1.1 rem maybe 1.2
yeah that looks good and then
let's also give this some padding
all the way around
and
i forgot to actually
apply the flex properties so let's give
this a flex of one just so occupies a
bit of its own space
um let's give it a background color
of white
and the color of the
icon
green and then
the border
let's make it green
solid 2 pixels classic border radius so
that's looking pretty good and i think
in the demo this has a hover effect so
let's actually apply a transition to
this
to
0.3 seconds
grab this
and then apply the hover
and let's change the background color
to
green
and the color of the icon
to
white
so let's go ahead and see if that's
working as you can see it's got a nice
hover effect now so we know that we're
going to need to click on this to add a
task now we're not completely done with
the styling as you'll see in a moment
when we um enter a task but let's first
add that functionality of adding a task
to our to-do list so let's go into the
javascript file and then we can start to
enter tasks after this so let's head
into our project 5.js file
so first things first in the javascript
we're going to need to create some
variables one for the actual button here
one for the input and then one for the
task container which is going to hold
all the tasks
so we'll do the first one
put comment here first
variables
and we'll say
add
task
equals document dot get element get
element by id
so the add task button
has the id of add
task
and then one for the task container
we'll call this variable task container
it's going to equal
document dot
get element
by id
id of task
container and then we're gonna have one
for
the input task
document
dot get element iid
and this is gonna again be for our input
which has the id of
input task
so we've got our variables the next
thing we want to do is create an event
listener for our add button here which
is pretty much going to hold
all of the power
so
say
event listener
for
add button
so we'll say add task which is that
variable there
add event listener we're going to look
out for a click event
and this is a function
and inside of this function the first
thing we're going to do is create div
and then we're going to store it inside
a variable of task
so we'll say let task equals document
dot create
element and we're going to be creating a
div
and this div is essentially just going
to house um our
task as well as that extra functionality
of the check button and the delete
button
so we're also going to want to give this
task
a class
so we can style it
this is going to have
class of task
so we've got our div there now we're
going to need to insert a list item for
the actual task itself as well as that
again that functionality of the check
button and the delete button so first
we'll do the list item
it's going to equals document dot create
element i'm going to create an li
then we're going to want to and then for
this list item we're going to want to
display that text that we insert in the
input or the value so to do that
i'm going to grab the li
variable and then we're going to say
inner
text is going to equal
and we'll do backticks here
and then we'll insert that variable of
input
task got the value again it's just what
the value is that we're going to be
inserting so whatever task we insert
inside of our input
and then of course we're going to want
to append this
inside of that div which is the variable
of task so we'll
append the li so now we've got our list
item the next thing we want to include
now is the check button and the delete
button so we can include some extra
functionality when we do insert a task
so
so we'll say
let's create a variable called check
button this is going to equal
document dot create
element and we'll create
our button
and then we'll say uh let's include the
icon in here so we'll say check button
dot in uh html
is equal to
i
say class of
f8 solid
it's insert the quote marks there
so fa solid fa check
and then we'll just close that off
and then we obviously need to style this
so we need to include a class
and
check
task
and we'll say task dot
append child
and then obviously you need to include
this inside of our div
so we'll just say task
start append
child and then we'll append the
check button and then we'll duplicate
this
for our
delete button
change release to delete
button and then
this one has trash
can
and then let's also change the class to
delete
task
so we've created all the elements we're
going to need to include in our task
the next thing we need to do now is just
make sure this actually shows and
appears in our browser when we try and
add a task so
that will say if
and actually i first just want to show
you that we have a bit of validation
here so if we take a look at the demo
example if we try and enter a task
without actually entering anything in
the input you can see we get this alert
box which has please enter task so for
this button to work we need to either
add a task or it's going to show us this
alert box to tell us to enter a task um
just so it's like a bit of validation to
the project
so to do that we'll say if
input
task dot the value so whatever value we
put inside of our input
is equal to
nothing then we'll include that alert
box
please
enter
a
task
so we'll just see if that's working as
you can see that alert box is working
so i'll say else
then grab the task container
which is going to be the container
houses or the task then we're going to
append
child and we're going to append that
task which houses um the check button
the list item and the delete button so
we'll just close that off and we'll see
now if this works so we'll enter a task
say collect
shopping hit enter and as you can see
there it's included our list item and
it's also included our two buttons that
we created obviously we're gonna be
starting this in just a moment but one
other thing i want to do just before we
go into the style sheet and style this
is that i want this to revert back to
the placeholder text instead of holding
the
value we put in the input
so uh to do that just grab the input
task variable
and the value
we want this to equal nothing so if we
go ahead and type that out again
collect
shopping
enter that you see it adds the list item
but it also removes it from the input so
we can insert another task so we're
almost nearly done here inside of the
javascript we'll come back and add the
functionality um to the checkbox and the
delete button but first let's just start
all of this so it just looks a lot nicer
and easier to work with so head back
into the style sheet
so let's apply the styling now for our
um
tasks when they get added to the list so
we'll just put a comment here saying
styling for tasks
which get
added to
the
list
so first we'll grab the
tasks which is the div which is going to
house all of that content so we're going
to just give this a width of
100
and then we're going to give this a
background color
of white so we can actually see the
content
um
let's also
give this some
broader radius
about 10 pixels and then
also the box shadow always love a bit of
box shadow
and then um
add a bit of padding here now
say about
five pixels
and let's push this down a bit actually
from
our enter tab there so let's
give this a margin
bottom of 20 pixels
so just to separate the two
and then let's also
give this a bit margin bottom as well so
it separates um all of the content all
of the tasks a little bit so just say
five pixels
and then let's grab display
flex
and let's say justify content
space between
and then let's now grab the list items
itself
so dot task
li
remove the list style
put a point
let's give this a flex of four
so it takes up most of the space
uh let's give it a bit of padding
about five pixels
and let's increase the font size of
these
to say uh
let's say 1.2 rem
a bit bigger 1.3
it looks good and then
let's give this a bit of margin as well
10 pixels
now as for the buttons themselves grab
the task grab the buttons
and we'll give these a flex of one
and let's also
give these rounded edges so border
radius 10 pixels
and then the background color of these
to be uh
let's make them white
now let's grab the um
items themselves actually let's change
the cursor to a pointer as well so let's
grab the task dot
check
task
it's going to have a color of orange
and let's give them a bit of space and
margin
right
five pixels
and the border
say solid
two pixels orange
and let's increase the font size of the
tick there to let's say 1.5 ram
it's looking good
and then let's
do a similar thing for the delete
delete
task
but instead of color orange i have the
color of
red
i don't have any margin on this
but we'll change this to red
and let's
decrease the font sizes to say
1.3 yeah it looks better
now both of these have a hover effect so
let's
do the check first
say background color change that to
orange
and then the color
to white
copy this therefore
the delete task
and the background color is going to be
red color's going to be white
so we'll hover over these and you can
see
those are working so all we need to do
now is just go to the javascript and
apply the functionality to this so
inside of our event listener here we go
underneath the input task value there
and then we'll say check
button
so add event listener we're going to
look out for a click event function
and we're going to say
check button and then because we need to
go
one element above um we need to traverse
the dom so just like we learned in part
one we're gonna grab the parent element
i'm gonna say dot style
dot text
decoration
and this is going to equal
line
through
so we'll check if that works
so let's enter a task
as you can see it's putting a line
through um our content there now let's
do one more for
the delete button
and we'll add an event listener to this
and
we'll look out for a click event
grab the function
we're going to need the event object
and we're going to say
let
target
equals e dot target which if you
remember back to part one this is
reference in the actual element that's
been clicked
and then we want to grab the target and
then grab the parent element twice
so we need to traverse the dom two times
and then we want to press remove
so with the target here we're
referencing the trash can or the bin or
delete button one level up there's a
list item and then one level above that
is the task so that's how it will remove
it and then we'll just add this to um
we'll just check this is working sorry
so we'll enter this task collect
shopping
and then if we click the check button it
will cross it out indicating that it's
been completed and then if we want to
delete it we just press the delete
button here
so we can add
more than one value here so collect
shopping add that
and we'll do another one for
walk the dog
add that and then we can
cross this out we can delete the collect
shop in as you can see the to-do list is
fully functional so that's actually
going to be it for this project guys
again the style wasn't really the
prettiest for this project again this
wasn't really the point of the project
of course this was more about how we can
manipulate the dom but this now also
concludes the part two video of dom
manipulation i hope you guys enjoyed the
video and learned a lot throughout the
two-part course be sure to leave it a
like and leave any questions in the
comments below that you may have and
i'll see you guys in the next video